mais là on est partis vad pour ce gros
match le gros classiques du grand gesso
j'ai envie de dire entre les deux
favoris de l'épreuve
oui et donc j'ai regardé un peu leur
partie récente et il y en a des signes
alarmistes comme je dois dire parce que
ce dernier semble ainsi maxime a réussi
contrairement à news quand même en place
parce que dans les autres cas dans ce
cas un homme dur dur donc par contre je
pense que ce que je peux aider
maxime ce soir c'est que j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas tout à fait
de compte
maxime que magnus va jouer aujourd'hui
j'écoute ma nièce je pense qu'on marque
nous c'est le plus tôt en train de se
battre contre les fantômes contre les
ombres des grands champions maintenant
il joue plutôt pour l'histoire là je
pense que il ce pas plutôt content
l'ombre d'un fischer car pauvre kasparov
auger pas liqin peut-être à fil d'or
surtout pour le surmoi polymorphie mais
je vais dire qu'ils ont comme je vois
pas de vraie concurrence aux échecs
moderne
à l'aller celle de plus hautes oui donc
je pense que oui
je pense que donc il n'a pas trop trop
d'intérêt sportif pour mac news par
contre la dimension historique et là tu
veux dire intérêt sportif par rapport à
ses adversaires directs son intérêt
sportif c'est un oui est ce que je suis
en train de jouer contre smith l'offre
aujourd'hui mercredi avec quelque chose
comme ça mais je vais dire que
maintenant je pense qu'il est en train
de regarder quels sont les recours
mondiale le nombre de partis pas perdus
où le nombre de parties gagnées défilé
le nombre des victoires dans l'étau des
soupirs tournoi enfants je veux dire qu
il est en train de se renseigner de
presser l'armée pas d'après qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont exactement fonce vers c'est
aujourd'hui ou demain posture n'est pas
tellement matin juste et c'est moins que
le 10 mois qu'on doit considérer en tant
que pas son très grand fan à 4 mais je
me suis exprimé déjà sur le sujet
récemment je pense surtout chaîne que
j'expliquais bien mon petit coeur se
disant comme la façon comment il joue
cette année là bien sûr ce point
critique et a rien à dire c'est là
maintenant et les bonbons déjà un peu on
peut constater qu il va rentrer dans
l'histoire en tant que l'un des plus
grands champions de tout le temps il
évident je pense qu'ils ont d'ailleurs
tous ceux qui ont récemment et leur
annoncer qu'ils sont ces deux héros
moment qui sont ces héros d'après toi
qu'est capable en cas ceux qui vivent
maintenant ce qui arrivera vraiment
beaucoup ce jour qui sont ces deux euros
kasparov kramnik non non les deux jouent
encore à les deux joues encore et que
lorsque tu regardes ce parti il est vrai
il est en vouloir influencer vos
branchements à quoi franchement ils vont
truc
ok tu vas pas répondre bon donc c'est
alpha 0 et daniel de bauve d'ailleurs
sûrement assez banalement c'est
intéressant
donc bannir de beauf ce wiki fossum se
contente depuis plus ou moins un an je
pense je pense que ça c'est commencer
assez banalement même leur relation
parce que au cours de l'été à 2 à
batoumi je pense que daniel s'approcher
en magnus ont eu du mal à esquiver
offert du pit
ils ont fait d'oublier et donc bave pas
fléau partenariat et commencer un peu
comme nous ouais donc pour toi aussi tu
as 2 0 donc c'est ok je vois ça tu es en
moi je mets 2 0 alors attends on va dire
un peu bon jour à tout le monde là parce
que du coup on part deux choses un jour
tu ailles acoyer qui les lie à louga
yamar fans mammare fans ricky rubio et
21 victor colin younès mozart idel
mohamed camara mike ronnie des richters
kewin akiyo in press kevin remercier
lookée watch rôles n 6 qui nous dit est
ce que ce match contre carl ça n'est pas
une opportunité empoisonné pour mvl s'il
se fait massacrer il risque de prendre
un coup au moral juste avant un tronc à
décisif non et que tant de gens prennent
terme des courtes que le poids de
kérosène qui a un peu plus être vraiment
démoralisé moins six locaux
tout simplement parce que s'il ya
quelque chose de banal qui arrive nos
jours laisse de terrain d'être
écrasé par 400 postes aux quelque chose
de réécouter il est vrai je suis
influencé par ce que j'ai vu récemment
mais c'est toujours ce que leur dernière
partie et qu'est-ce que j'ai eu peur
j'ai vu que ma news a gagné à ça grimpe
avec les bons à la partie classique et
laganière rapide aux états unis avec les
besoins et les derniers blitz avec les
bancs et la gagner donc avec le noir la
partie classique
en gros ces derniers temps blaise bas et
les copeaux blanc que à sa vie hors
impôts que difficilement battable alors
il ya acheté catalans qui dit bonjour au
chat et qui lui dit bonjour il ya alex
versons sissao night gilles barbotte
mario gasparini des bombes dance est ce
que c'est un table non tu connais un des
sceaux qui y sera plus rapide que tu
disque a perdu magnus pardon et il nous
dit dans le chatt lissot qui s'est vue
serait plus facile de dire ce que magnus
a perdu tu te dire que ce qu'il a gagné
a donc maintenant par contre comme
d'habitude je peux essayer de faire les
pronostics aussi cette dernière tombe la
magnus a commencé sa partie contre
hambourg il a joué les quatre premières
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ira que voler
et fera au prix qu'avait les trois
premiers j'en suis plus ou moins sûr
pourquoi parce que c'est la stratégie et
intègre une fête parce que donc au cours
de ces dernières années la maxime a
signé deux systèmes contre cela premier
avec ce sens que le c6 deuxième avec 56
a pas trop marcher dans les mailles
incisive dernièrement mary dan leo 2
chaque fois ça n'a pas trop trop bien
marché donc ça nous v'la ben saleh
délègue le génial génie visuel et sonore
vous connaissez tous donc je pense que
donc il ya un trou qui vient de s'ouvrir
et récemment et donc je pense que
cavalière 3 voilà voilà bien visé et
quand tu vois un trou où tu iras donc
comme à l'e3 alors est intéressant donc
avec quoi les beats stoppeur français
sont élevées cette fois ci les choses
ont changé les roues et tout patrick
manent en formule 1 ils font les
changements de roues en une seconde 8 ah
bon c'est le reccord peut-être revoir
même seconde cinq mois je sais pas la
voiture arrivait s'arrêtent les mecs
font vous vu les voitures partent mais
combien demain quinzaine des mecs
donc quand même plus que maxime a dans
sa position
mais c'est impressionnant quand ils
arrivent et moi sûrement moins creux sur
moi moi que le nombre d'heures de jeu
c'est pas mal car j'ai appris
lille mon avis qui il a déjà travaillé
dans ce lit mais j'ai halluciné
ça nous rappelait quelque chose à vlad
en 8 secondes les cirques banon 5 voilà
je ne cesse pas de nous améliorer
on peut pas si sérieux deux minutes avec
chaque wii donc qu'on va lire trois pit
stop de la part de mars
est-ce qu'ils ont pareil quand ils vont
chiottes les joueurs d'échecs
imagine tu arrives aux toilettes elles
atteignent punch de quinze mecs
équiterre qui couvrait te pousse comme
asie que je savais que j'avais quand mon
pit stop
à coruche quoi c'est bon tu peux
repartir alors s'il va enregistrer
surprise c'est la seule raison pourquoi
les hommes jouent plus pour que le fond
c'est plus long parce que quand même une
mine de 0,8 tu vas pas vu là tu va de
bart a fait pour c'est génial que
tiendraient révolutionner les
explications sur les échecs féminin
passe d'ailleurs le championnat d'europe
1 rapide du blitz et ensuite de se
terminer
pas loin de chez nous à monaco donc est
historiquement je pense je sais pas
quand la dernière fois est ce que ça se
produit que une participante à doubler
le titre dont kosteniuk bras obama dira
bravo et la gagner les deux et
d'ailleurs blitz et la wii blitz et la
gagner seul donc ce que eux aussi assez
impressionnant ça commence à quelqu'un
ça commence à 17 heures ça commence
maintenant ça va commencer
c'est en train de commencer sauf s'il
n'y a pas des inondations ou se remet
hier c'était fou et les inondations au 1
il y avait les sirènes tout mais ce à
jour d'ailleurs à l'oignon entre landes
a donc il peut avoir les inondations
aussi d'air quand tu as in march faisait
l'ouverture non dit c'est rémy parfois
oui parfois ce sont des bois en fait ça
ça dépend moyens quand maxime joue avec
les noirs avaient peur ils se disent
jamais son invention tout ce qui est
toujours du mal comme maxime joue avec
les noirs sont toujours les points qui
décide de qui soit c'est ce que younes
qui se demande si on peut expliquer en
quoi consiste ce tournoi alors il va y
avoir des partis en longues deux parties
en cadence longue
je crois que ces quatre partis en rapide
et quatre partis en lice mais peut-être
que quelqu'un peut nous envoyer un lien
parce qu'en fait j'ai beaucoup galéré à
trouver leur du tournoi à kevin
peut-être diplôme explique à manier ces
trois au la surprise ça c'est du jamais
vu ça c'est du jamais vu là est ce qu il
veut parce que bien sûr cinq mois
cinq noms cavalière 3 ha ha non c'est
impressionnant quand même ouais comme en
corse et poivrons pilier relate mais
pendant ce temps de nostradamus eh oui
notre dame jusqu'à main pour ce que j'ai
dis quoi car les toits plats de demain
oui mais alors quoi choquer c'était très
faso et au sérieux aujourd'hui c'était
facile
ah non le cavalier revenu en géant alors
qu'en laissant vos valeureux 1,4 à c'est
un gosse qui voulait tout cas je suis
pas sûr que les premiers coups dont
nombre des quatre repas non quand même
pas ok c'est dès que le d4 que les
chiffres soient si je voulais dire qu'il
va jouer l'idée de cornets de compteurs
nages 2 au fait qu'est-ce que c'est
compliqué ça voulait l'utiliser c'est
cornet qui la met donc à l'espoir et
c'est ok alors j'ai trois fouilles deux
fautes 3 3 ou coiffeuse ou cinq on est
un peu développé ok judy jeudi qu'
aujourd'hui ils voient frères faut 3
[ __ ] terry g4 ou g5 faut que ça cache
sous sol il voit jouer l'été deux contre
deux grilles chaque partie gris chaud
kemble eu l'idée de fleurs on va voir
là c'est tout le suspens quelles
garanties choisies fou j'ai 5
waouh quel courage de se faire les
messages s'il faut trois conditions
d'équité c'est guéri qui a des bons
résultats avec sa contre maxime faut 2,5
oui parce qu'ils se moquent touche
2 et révélées de ses connaissances et 6
heures ok je pense que cela en vaut elle
n'a jamais été de l'humour de jouer
cavalier de cette moto gosselies contre
6,1 contre fauché cinq pardon donc aussi
c'est normal par contre c'est
intéressant en france f4 nawa à la moins
chère amie l'a amené en train de
commander a assisté à une révolution est
mineur parce que f3 ici j'aime lieu de
les grosses parties mais par contre
c'est facile d'expliquer les personnes
je le fais pourquoi contre n'importe qui
le système presque sauf aussi quatre
bogeys sainte maxime jours e st à
l'instar de officier à franchir a
toujours lié l'idée d'un espace agora g5
ou toujours software ce cas tu es refuge
et s'incline donc qu'est ce qu'il veut
il veut donc provoqué d'abord ici et
maintenant f3 parce qu'il veut revenir
après on se tape de l'attaquant bojan la
dame de grave on a écouté mais bon c'est
pas la première fois et sûrement pas la
dernière mais ça n'a jamais eu france
traversé mon petit quoi est ce que tu
penses que seydou ba bien possible parce
que du beau fils est partout maintenant
dans le jour du mariage
je pense qu'il ya un certain si tu veux
manitou profond donne le dans les
parties du monde nous sommes peut-être
même un peu trop
oui mais je peux reprendre ces dernières
35 parties et vous montrer les traces
d'obtenir un peu partout c'est très sale
blague et que tu t'assieds sur leurs
épaules qu'il soit les frontières de la
liberté sans excès
non là c'est sûr tu as comme c'est le
problème sinon il n'y a pas de limite
mais tu sais c'est comme blood vinik
quoi assieds toi sur léman quoi faire
oui bon ça m'étonnerait si mag news va
pas faire maintenant que voilier bête de
cet opus nous aimerions remercier quand
les baies de cette bouffe aux cavaliers
de 7 d'un côté et très souple de l'autre
côté peut-être tu voudrais je connais
ses six plus tard note comme maxime
pouliot fait jamais il voit jouer donc à
l'époux de septembre 7.5 silva deuxième
pronostics sylvain chess dans le chat
nous dit que ça est déjà été joué à un
haut niveau une seule fois par ragots
zine en col soviétique écoles soviétique
et qui était à gosier pour votre nuque
touati nullement je m'appelle bobigny
magazine pour hbo dominique a été tous
bords pour mac news j'ai pas sucre oui
et d'ailleurs parmi les méthodes
d'entraînement de plus sain que bedenik
employés c'est au cours de leur parti
innombrables
d'un trait noir il par exemple il a mis
de la musique
il a il a par les enfants gedo faisait
tous les obstacles possibles pour qui
sait ça devient dur pour le tour de jeu
les trucs les plus simples possibles des
trucs les plus impossibles et pourquoi
ok c'est de l'esprit faut être con
totale quoi ouais ouais
n'oublions pas à l'époque c'était même
possible de fumer pendant que je vais te
mettre les cigarettes je vais te mettre
un petit peu de mozart as tu me fais ça
tu me fais ça et pourtant un peu tout
pas quoi et pour toi que deux bonhommes
de l'hérault est pour toi le remix de
lutte et de l'argent boum boum c'est
n'importe quoi donc écouter encore ne
pouvaient pas espérer mieux que ça nous
les spectateurs
je suppose ce nom nous les commentateurs
évolué spectateurs parce que il est vrai
que c'est pas ce genre de position qui
s'annulent rapidement et sans trop de
fait c'est impossible donc là maintenant
qu'est-ce qui est en train de faire
maxime elle est en train de comprendre
quelle est la ligne d'analyser les
bleues devancent email pour l'éviter ou
et pour éviter donc est-ce que d'abord
il faut les voir y avait les 2 7 5
ouf je parlais de cette danse est de 5
est ce que les bornes d'abord et garde
une autre chose mais ils apprennent de
comprendre où ce culotté redoux cherche
quoi donc même c'est ce que je suis en
train de me dire si tu es maxime à ce
moment-là peut-être tu penses à
jérusalem lui faire ici quoi j'ai envie
d'aller jouer le grand prix de jérusalem
est n'est ce pas qu'est ce que je fous
là
d'ailleurs pour se plaindre si tu leur
masser prendre tu peux commencer comme
que je suis pas fou de cette fois ci ce
ne sera pas puni pour tu peux le faire
d'ailleurs ça peut très facilement
transformé à 11 heures fou de cette dame
2 que voler ses six grandes retenir et à
nice
sauf que c'est une bonne ligne pour les
bons et on peut pas faire h6 faut trois
à un cavalier de cette énergie c'est
bien profitable
comme quoi profitable pour les noirs
donc après ashes frêche en sachant ça
joue pas donc faut trois mois je joue
bien fort est ce que tu peux expliquer
pourquoi ici c'est profitable un bon
achat ne redonne des doubles 5e après g4
le couple précise l'un d'eux coût
principal c'est donc c'est un problème
d'ailleurs quand moi je vais en train
d'analyser à six fours trois ans il faut
3 que voyager 5% 15 6 pouces et en a
converties six le challenge était de
comprendre dans quelles lignes 6 et
profitable bois mais est ce que moi tu
as d'ailleurs pas ce clou en photo près
peut-être une fois et je vous dis toi et
moi je trouve infondée 3e 5e volet 2 2
pourra plus tard m sûr je crois et les
noirs auront peut-être mois de vie de
jouer je suis parce que si ce grand prix
sport qu'on avait expliqué tout ça ouais
ouais donc alors h 6 x 4 mai aps il est
vrai le vous sur un score très con quoi
sous ce nom un petit peu zarbi et je
peux pas faire d'investissement
tu peux mer là je suis bien préparée
contre je suppose mais parce qu après qu
elle ait pas trois il n'y a pas de
chèques sur 3 1 n'ont rien de chèques
sur trois mois il n'y a pas de puits en
oeuvre quatre reprises
ce qui est important donc ici d'un
baissier ce pas tout à fait car j'en
mets tu vas faire fouetter un jour pour
chasser le chaos
parce que lorsque le plan sur quatre de
jeu enfin je sens que c'est sur 4 h 6 a
été la favorite
de maxime pendant comptable et après
quoi les deux jours à toi donc on les
bats toi je suis justement
oui les bourgeois 3 et après les
branches jour ou deux pour chasser la
terre et qui après se développe pour
naturellement avec damas trois gros
coups ici ce serait un cas manière 4 way
ici ça va pas être obligés sauf qu'ils
ont peut-être après rachid force 4
d'anglicismes four doux est impossible
d'en bas 2 que l'a4 moi c'est toi le
génie de patikul bas je vois pas cette
tourbe et agissent même est tombé en
bessin j'ai voulu faire ça rien que les
possibles mouais je suis très content
avec damas catholique est agitée
monsieur louis et vous quoi que tu crois
que tu as ta ta ta trois pièces
oui mais je fois ci se s'y colle et ses
six enfants
sinon mieux dans ce thriller dit tu vas
être mieux puisque leur didier galles et
le matériel en faveur des blancs est à
moitié car il couvre les trois déjà je
serais content mais est le problème
dentelle fourrure h4 qui viennent si
haut après disons h 6/4 fawcett y aura
un tas de trucs tactique pas impossible
aussi d'un mode deux peut-être que
quatre jeux à part peut-être mais
sûrement fausses vérités d'aujourd'hui
que les enfants et ya pas de [ __ ] sa
merde c'est ça il faut se sait que le
droit non mais on veut juste montrer que
ça va être des trucs qui vont croire
donc peut-être
ah oui et si tu joues dans deux d'entre
eux deux au lieu tant il a joué six faux
droits
où ils vont venir alors il veut jouer
cette formation depuis un convoi
désagréable pour son adversaire sans
avoir joué g4 je voudrais juste mais
jeter un invité dans cette structure de
pions mais je pense qu'à deux buts bon
c'est pas grave je veux faire aucune
photo dr au pire faire 4 4 à 4 mois mais
jusqu'à la fin de cette partie [ __ ] tu
vois je il est donc tu vois des tests et
avis quoi en fait il veut juste dire
j'accepte de perdre 0,2 point au 1er mai
oui on est chez moi
oui mais ta radio tu arrêtes du mois
d'août bouger même mais ça c'est bien
jouer tu vois ça c'est ce que toi tu
m'as appris à faire jouer les positions
que les autres aiment pas oui on m'a
toujours dit que c'était fantastique de
faire ça c'est très bien joué 1 c'est
moi donc pour les prochains coups s'il
faut hausse est par exemple je prévois
food très bien joué et rock fawcett fou
de rock randy dans nos écoles et ses 6
et les questions c'est à chaque fois est
ce que les noirs si j'aimais n'ont pas
de nom je pense pas dans ce document
parce que cavaler de 4%
je pense pas que tu dois me donner trop
de libérer les cinq à trois tempo ok moi
maintenant au moins ne l'a pas de calais
sécession au moins pour un petit instant
donc comme hautement elle va faire quoi
on peut retrouver cette force est la
douleur donc et l'autre voire un peu
ouvrir ce cas je pense que ça va être de
toute manière serait de faux documents
je suis persuadé n'en joue pas mal hein
manu bon bon bon bon se trouve trop de
trucs bien trop tôt de dire quand même
nom mais géré par excès mal an le choix
de l'ouverture vraiment mal en mai
escaut
le problème avec eux maxime ce qui est
assez souvent tu peux le voir dès
l'ouverture
oui soit greenfield soi mais geof mais
le problème c'est qu'ici les positions
où il convient de toute manière il voit
il voit pas donc rentrer dans des
analyses de toute manière il voit il va
déposer des gros problèmes pratiques à
l'artois n'y marc fans riquiqui ne dit
pourquoi elle venait mre pas ça ça a
l'air pas si mal pour les noirs c'est
parce qu'on va mettre ça déjà c'est
parce que les variantes my stuff qui
ouvrait la porte à chaque fois il
préfère jouer avec le pion sur eux cinq
fois sur six donc ils préfèrent les
formations des billons purement hamage
d'offres et pas se baigner ou bien qu'on
peut dissocier d'habitude sauf que ici
il est vrai il est vrai il est déjà pas
mal réussi parce qu' il ait peu joué
ensemble dans un coup donc parce que le
toit ne veut pas assez de temps pour à
80 donc en gros ce même si sa cheville
en guyane bien sûr normalement c'est une
bonne version de chewing gum
scheveningen ses rangs pour expliquer
ces les pions e6 des 6 et maxime
d'habitude ce qu'il essaye de faire leur
part en bijoux h3 qui a un coût très
typique séduit avec la la structure des
6 500 qui s'appelle le trou de bourgogne
boeuf ou boleslav si bonne soit parce
qu'ils leur estime de soi ce qui est
plutôt et fisher a toujours joué de
cette manière lorsque j'étais gosse je
un âge d'or du tournoi dure neuf quoi
mais c'est ça j'ai aussi jamais réussi
de jouer avec les pions des saucisses
par contre déçu samedi parce qu'ils
voient ce village grec avait libéré sept
shenyang m
ok ça se crée un peu différemment a
peut-être c'est une blague sharingan h
et rien qu'au début de cette écoute et à
quel titre max sait mieux que moi
terrain je serais pas si rapide je vais
pas être je secoue aussi rapidement pour
avoir
avoir la possibilité de coventry si
jamais donc moi je rêvais plutôt fou
possède je pense
ouais j'avoue que je ne sais pas
spécialiste sur le sujet alors jeune
nikki 96 sont vraiment deux heures
chacun pour jouer ouais tout à fait ils
ont deux heures chacun pour jouer et
bien parti il des mavs est ce que c'est
possible de jouer que dans des piles
mais malheureusement il est vrai
malheureusement les organisateurs en
pose toujours parfois cette cadence bien
sûr bien radio et c'est pas près de
changer
ah ouais et même si je t'ai le
commentateur officiel sur la chaîne
officiers jeridi les mêmes choses tiens
il défie de nouveau mes pronostics qui
au lieu d'être
ils joignent au maroc il veut quand même
je grande roue malgré le fait que la
marche du piol jay est déjà stoppée
d'emblème par le bios sur six
quelle surprise comme peut-être je
comprends pas vraiment à ce que se
passent ces jeux là vous quoi vous
retire mans mais tu penses qu'il a fallu
recomposer va faire foule de petits rock
ben si tu veux je obtiendront qu'il faut
de tout doute s'il ne fait pas ce qu'il
veut vraiment leur avocat et donc il
s'en fout que g4g kth cat
il y aura encore il faudra un deux trois
cours de préparation pour pouvoir pour
ce 5e jeu 4 h 4 et la turque sur un char
mais
n'est pas protégé donc il faudra fuir en
courant coup j'en à tour jean mais que
tête l'intérêt lui même en est rentré
dans les lignes principales de rem et
maxime il attaque va réussir maintenant
ces trucs là mais toi tu les connais pas
ouais mais maxime il est super bon dans
cette position là je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec toi pour vous la tuque en
sait qu'il cadas pour les partir dont 40
minutes de jeu quand c'est fortement de
ne pas jouer les portes du tout mais
comme ça en impose et malheureusement
les forces et après je mettrais combien
de temps pour une partie longue du
couple pour toi ça devrait être comme la
cadence la plus longue
quand voire 25 85 et raflé plus haut
possible avec dix secondes de rajouts et
le reste pour les les maisons de répéter
et y en a beaucoup
baby boom la pyramide j'ai la pyramide
des âges qui en train de se renverser
donc tu proposes des partis classiques
pour payer les retraites vous faut pas
l'avouer on me demande ça dure à jouer
au 40e coup n'y a pas de rajout du coup
là dans le grand duché souris long
mettre beaucoup de temps au début deux
heures et dix minutes mais ils donnent
pas de rage ou écouter bas les parties
rapides à vendre les coeurs panneaux les
partis classiques avant les parties
rapides mais rappelle les préliminaires
sexuelle qui s'arrête pas pendant 2h 3h
quoi tu vois ben ça doit commencer quand
même abandonné tu vois ce que je
comprends que tu vois tes qualités
français et tout mais ouais
arrêtons quand même les jours
préliminaire sexuelles pendant 14 heures
calmes voire plus un peu trop
je connais pas assez détail de ta vie
quoi j'ai jamais été là pour y assister
malheureusement à ce qu'ils vont aller à
mada c'est un détail de nos vies c'est
donc ça ma vie est en ordre
c'est donc savoir ce qu'il souhaite
c'est donc ça ma vie c'était dans sa
famille c'est donc ça nos vies même
peut-être plus tôt et c'est un groupe
marseillais n'ont genre iam ou la fonky
family mais on va nous dire dans le
tchat
ouais donc bon d'autres manières dames 2
écoutez maintenant il ya deux ans s'ils
reviennent aux échecs soif ou possède
avec l'idée de jeu de simple dames est
d'ailleurs assez souvent
après eux d'un tu prends pas avec
lecavalier mais tu prends avec le fou
pour que après cavale et de sa qualité
5b kateri toujours jeunes cavaliers
joyce d'ailleurs c'est le premier pas
alors pour booster de 5
deuxième point existe en ce domaine en
cavale et sur bussy l'aude sur 17 pour
sermonner sur son compte mais après ces
quatre parfois pousser l'autre point est
donc ni l'un ni l'autre un bio juste de
deux points de maîtrise j'ai croqué tout
cas c'est incroyable mais plus tard
c'est fini pour elle c'est quoi sa série
savoir perdre en fait les prem's et qui
va jouer des parties amateurs en ligue
norvégienne je passais au courant a ok
mais ça ça compte
ainsi si ça compte et alors qu'on garde
la foi et je crois il a battu deux mecs
à 2003 alors je veux dire qu'on garde
des parties de jouées sans ouvrir donc
je crois à 103 104 a plus que ses envies
d'accord mais il devrait pas trop
s'amuser contre les mecs qui ont moins
de 2003 ça peut être dangereux parfois
il y a un grand mère qui a touché
plusieurs voix 2007 dont je veux pas
citer le nom qui s'y dit qui obtient je
veux obtenir un genre 2030
ce que n'ont jamais réussi si je joue
des petits open woods je veux que cette
occupation
il a fait trois ou cinq tentatives et
n'a jamais réussi finalement parce qu'à
chaque fois il était proche de ce projet
2006 30
mais ça lui est arrivé craint de perdre
après avoir gagné dans la cave partie
des filets oui je devine deux derniers
coupe h5 horrible horrible juste
horrible donc le pari de magnus magnus a
déjà appuyé a déjà porté ses fruits
puisque recharge pas bon pour voir ce
que pour jouer ça mais le plus on achète
olympio marchés séparés et toute autre
manière il ya disons que
c'est juste pas en ligne et donc elle ne
puis on a été déjà bien sûr agissent
donc horrible en tant que réflexe c'est
très critique en fait inédit c'est
meilleur que derrière d'après le redis
je m'en fous c'est n'importe quoi c'est
carrément n'importe quoi horrible comme
réflexe est d'ailleurs joué à la vitesse
incroyable comme à qui est-ce qui ont
maintenu se comprend bien
oui vous savez il y avait le livre de ce
désert gligoric le grand maître
légendaire serre et aux brestois qui
était très bon ami sicilienne qui était
très bon partout et le titre de son
livre l'un de mes préférés lorsque je te
jure on a été je joue contre les pièces
où je t'ai toujours contre cette
approche là parce que je pense pas qu'il
faut jouer contre les pièces et puis il
faut bien sûr je continue donc et donc
ce système la maintenir ce n'est jamais
pour employer contre qui que ce soit
dans les rythmes qui au contraire maxime
peut-être parce que maxime est capable
d'un tel coup commerçants à 6 5 mais
c'est moche non c'est vrai que ça paraît
juste dommage d'avoir perdu le tempo qui
nous a donné
bien sûr ce jusque dans ses listes aux
actes et intercity tu veux maxime n'a
pas voulu jouer avec un handicap
c'est peut-être le fouet comment attirer
leurs frères logo noir piano gaulle en
quoi logo boîte ou quoi ok tu me donnes
ça je te rends compte que tu vas 7,4 me
oui et en plus le nom mag news c'est
comme le nombre des romans oui toile et
on va le plus gros montant des dons
soient rejetés de ragots le potage
magique pourquoi je veux dire qu'il
appelait 20,6 lagrave x6 les grains vie
que jamais je te donnera les ja
dégage cette ville est à moi oui oui
c'est bien ça c'est bien ça et du coup
tu attends tu seras joueurs de druide
qui fait du thé matcha voilà druides
druid et yann à doha au moins dans ma
connaissance donc bruit des tirs
bach rixe et donc bruit de comment
s'appelle le bride cosmetics on dit en
train de réfléchir quand on entend les
pièces bouger mais rien ne se passe sur
l'échiquier c'est sur l'autre partie en
fait que ça bouge parce qu'on est les
deux parties ouvertes intiale et il y en
a d'autres qui jouent aussi deux autres
donc n'oubliez pas la bande le bar de
ludwig de large x
donc ça mais ça c'est quoi c'est plus ou
moins égales non ce truc je cette
impression là ce que je pense mais tu
sais j'ai inventé une règle pour les
stream quand les deux jouent très vite
très longtemps c'est nul
si les deux joueurs oui oui bien sûr
parce qu'en fait si les deux joueurs
vous bien la théorie et connaître
jusqu'au bout et ouais c'est que
j'aimerais galliano se termine mal pour
le spectateur
dis moi est ce que tu es le forum oui
moi non à un moment donné j'ai lu ou une
expression de goût fade que peut-être à
vous le spectateur connaissait danse
turn bon g auteur soviétique qui a dit
que la moitié des partis s'ils y ont été
perdus par les bons à cause du coup aux
abois et moi j'ai lu ben find
qui a dit qu'on fait comme j'ai toujours
bien r c'est pour ça qu'ils se posent
ce doit être ça les raisons mais en fait
à vrai dire ok matemale d'hôtel va faire
un coup comme j'ai pas tout suivi tout y
est allé on est de toute manière tu vas
ouvrir des cartes mais vous apprendre ça
sert à quoi maintenant hawaï et
peut-être de retour sur huit voire neuf
a donc visé le roi cela c'est bien trop
en quoi donc faussée par contre je suis
pas sûr non plus en fait ça me parait
d'être comme un coucou quoi un peu fini
toute manière les noirs veulent pas se
moquer est ce que le fou peut revenir
angers 5 nous demande de toute manière
tu vois m pato sur sweet d'envoi sifflé
le tout de suite quoi pourquoi fo se
maintenant tu t'attaques comme là bas
justement c'est ce que je suis en train
de me demande de me demander tu fais
quoi tu fait feu deux tours en f1 mais
simplement n'aura sûrement pas donc
normalement je pense je dois préparer
les pussycat peut-être pas chez toi
parce que 6 h 4 je suis bien sûr super g
3 3 et 4 howe est donc peut-être je joue
je crois peut-être dans le même style
quelque chose comme tour gens sinon que
ce que je faisais mon je fais gaffe si
mon adversaire
fais attention à vos bons sentiments
par contre je peux pas regagné le
sacrifice
depuis sur rue 6 je pense pas que
seraient les arrêts de jeu 3 france 3
c'est bien trop si chaque fois qu un
petit pour accueillir de toute façon des
premiers coups vlad est en désaccord
bien sûr bien sûr 6 à l'heure par
l'opposition de tous que presque tout ce
qui est bon en fait les noirs un complot
est ce qu'on peut dire que tu es dans
l'opposition le vla d' ange et sa vraie
oppositionnel donc chez à l'epo à la
pression à tous les deux this aux
dernières élections européennes on a eu
un parti politique qui était imparti un
animal je crois je suis quand il
s'appelle avait une photo de chats
dessus c'est parti à chaque fois pas
vraiment de visages peut-être que je
trouverai un parti d'opposition et homps
et actuel de sucre
je suis contre cette loi est très souple
sonnantes quoi en gros en gros le parti
de ceux qui sont toujours très soupçonne
encore ouverts ce qui se passe mais je
pense que ce serait très bien pour nous
tous il répété le portier non les
parties de soupçons non mais je pense
qu'en fait c'est le parti majoritaire en
france on est tout le temps en train en
valais
qu'est ce que tu connais un français
heureux tu connais notre spécificité
moral toujours un a d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça tu es passeport oui quand on
commence à trouver le temps d'améliorer
de vous mais renouvelle
ils n'ont pas vérifié mais que
précipiter mon vocabulaire ou quoi que
ce soit mais réseaux sociaux non
poitiers est-ce que je suis super
heureux et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
sam c'est un chef
bah écoutez je suis contre quoi et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette idée
j'aurais pas fait comme ça qu est ce que
vous pensez que c'est bien je crois
qu'ils sont complètement fous
les cartes d'identité passeports
diplomatiques
c'est très dur qui représente la france
en russie khl et ils doivent se dire
qu'elle plomb machiavélique d'avoir fait
rentrer le ver dans la pomme russe khl
dames 1 j'aurais sûrement pas jouer ce
coup en matière message la table il dit
phyto très rigolo mais il défie toutes
les règles de tous mais dis moi comment
est-ce que sont liés les bourreaux à
boire et damman na je sais pas mais
c'est quoi cette géométrie diouf qui
lisent de couleurs le prochain ça va
être quoi faut s'interroger d'ailleurs
logiquement oui il faut se risque à un
j'ai compris ça et comprimer you make
être joué aux échecs fischer
peut-être peut-être il cherche
l'harmonie un peu partout de à partir
d'une position idiot autres cherchent
comment foudre la mauny oui donc il veut
je le veux je vous sera alors manqué est
ce qu'une menace d'alger 3 je suis ce
qu'on réussisse d'habitude contre de thé
qu'on max sûrement pas parce qu'il ya
douze jours de la marche dont je suis à
temps à regarder genre tour s'est vite
dame g3 oui sinon je vais dire je fais
pas le coup je fais pas le court je fais
quoi que ce soit dans les 10 ans d'un
danger 3g pas
ok h4 ici ça marche à notre âge cette
dame jeu sans courage ça ici 2014
oui donc danger trois jeux menace pas
sérieusement oui donc emmènera jusqu'à 4
il veut quoi le territoire
waouh il veut mettre la dame / h pour
admirer ces chers pour menacer g4 oui et
attaquer réussissent dans certaines
variantes mais l'autre voie où le faire
mille fois moi tu as rejoint tous trois
et le reste
tant mieux tous trois et toi t'es quoi
je m'appelle m
non non non non non ça c'est bien trop
opportuniste quoi donc dans le miniou
nafoussa je suppose est ce que tu penses
car il sait pas les échecs où je suis
capable de commentaire je pense qu'il
vaut mieux que je prends une des murs a
bâti quoi parce que c'est pas les est ce
que je peux commenter parce que ce sont
dix films à comprendre ça me flatte tir
vicieux ce bar éclat qui risquerait de
cette perte qui pose toi pour que mon
désir de se taire oui mais bon ce qui
est fou c'est à l'heure et après quoi
wikitude eelv 4 2-4 vite de larges qui
j'ai écris tu fais quoi pour faire quoi
pendant une demi heure avec deux petites
reines de capac pascal houillier niveau
trop élevé pour vlad et oui oui salois
ivo karlovic itx qui lui dit à la blague
de la kevin donc peut-être ai-je 3 non
mais ça ne l'était au scot foule de noms
mais je pense que son idée c'est juste
de protéger le 4 et préparé quatre en
fait non mais peut-être que tu être
juste
6 3 l'idée h 14 55 faubourg phobos un
mets ton tour c8 ou c5 mais attend à je
crois tu nas quoi je sais je sais je
sais que je me lance pas juste je viens
de reprendre ces fous de sa colère 5-fu
cette dame ne s'est pas foulé simple non
mais c'est n'importe quoi je sais mais
au moins je sais de non mesdames 1 il me
protégeait le +1 4 l'accession ok donc
un studio peut-être un fiancé hier soir
il via avant s'endormir levier pour
s'endormir
il vient d'ouvrir le livre de nîmes ce
riche sur protection de tous ouais ils
fiables d'apprendre le terme
surprotection matters est vite joué mais
on va voir la cité ok retourne le
souffle par an par amp amp amp amp amp
amp amp amp amp amp amp amp sommes donc
alors taxés quand il se regarde de voir
deux jamie le premier plongeon des deux
parties en sortant de la théorie très
rapidement cela prouve la richesse du
jeu d'échecs ou sans aucun doute sans
aucun doute
regardez rajouter nous mais je comprends
pas du tout je comprend une source qui
veut faire et et blanc fait damien c'est
vraiment bizarre
le dis on n'a pas compris grand roque
non mais il fait aussi baby qu'il y va
je vois pas ce qu'il ya de si
impressionnant mais partie aussi ça sent
la théorie très rapidement donc
pas de noms mais fou c'est un ça paraît
logique en fait si tu veux comme ça et
b3 four b2 comme dans sa partie contre
roche taceq mon nom mais si c'est bien
ça c'est chose que je vais je serai le
premier à aplatir
je serai le premier là mais d'imaginer
si c'est ça ouais ne faut pas pourquoi
quand même ce serait extraordinaire non
fausse adams au 7 mai n'empêche des
trois lotos aussi à l'ol avait le niveau
d'eau new wave aussi pour s'endormir
donc il a appris le popoli
prophylactique fosse à un pilotage je
suis à 12h au complexe
c'est peut-être là prophylactique contre
des cavaliers ou quatre des tués est
peut-être là il va sortir son futur jeu
simple qui n'est pour le moment pas y
avait pas un cours que le kata bien sûr
non mais regarde de toute façon il n'y
avait pas à tenter de faire bouger 5
maintenant et sur carhaix de quatre
cavaliers français je sais que c'est ah
ok tu te trouves 2 x 4 et je tenir sur
les deux côtés quoi mais bon les plantes
la jetée beau linge de bourse des
banques est partout quoi en gros tu
bouges pas quoi et après je fouillais h
trois mois c'est ingérable et je creuse
mais dans ces cas là pourquoi dames deux
ans de toute façon parce que six fois je
serais très curieux
4 donc c'était le cours préparatoire qu
foods 2 x 4 pour donc jouer le parti le
plus filmé
une telle histoire de chèques non mais
si ces perles comme le 4 x 4 on comprend
pas pourquoi en tout cas pour le moment
mais n'hésitez pas de sortir vos
théories personne donnée théorie il ya
que peut-être quelqu'un qui a compris
beaucoup mieux que nos deux donc c'est
un endroit prestigieux je pense que tout
le monde joue à fond est ce que tu
penses que maxime joue à fond d'ailleurs
où est ce que tu penses qu'il cache un
peu ces trucs ou pas n'ont bien sûr le
jour où fo à fond toute façon qu'est-ce
qui les a cachés donc mauvais le vois
jouer son meilleur niveau elle a sans
doute pas de toute manière contre ma
news d'habitude ou du monde de
jousseaume max so far west soki d'aller
moitié des cas et prêts accordés mieux
de n'importe quelle position
ça fait neuf cent soixante oiseaux bien
il n'est pas prêt à accepter nul contre
grand monde
howe est ce que ça veut dire qu elle est
le plus deux joueurs parmi tous là je
penserai ça veut dire en fait il a été
tellement impressionnant 960
c'était incroyable d'ailleurs à discuter
avec un show comme plus haut je
regardais même pas trop les papiers de
du match car son sort et sasha a dit
qu'il peut se dire le niveau
dow est lié dans son match contre coeur
scène donc trois mille 3000 3000
tellement il est bien joué moi je sais
pas parce que je pars et garder ce parti
du coup qu'une seule épreuve je pense
que moi j'ai pas de dérive sur ce sujet
mais tu fais confiance à la viguerie de
choc quand même ouais t'as peur parce
que noir mat
tu sors pas de telles déclarations
facilement surtout sur un concurrent
direct
justement justement aux fauves dooku et
bitam jeu 3 bac g3 ramadi le problème
ch4 et d'amos trois autres offres et le
petit poney qui a l'air de regarder avec
l'ordi dick sur dame j'ai trois tours
france et 3 gagne 6 juste direct ce qui
est pas étonnant amati - on admire une
fois du même nom moti mois qui viennent
tu peux m'expliquer s'il te plaît
comment maxime s'est qualifié pour cette
finale mais il a gagné les grandes
chaînes tours paris oui il a dû faire un
autre grande pièce où il avait bien fini
en deuxième troisième en afrique ou rsi
que s'ouvrait et puis après la sinne que
phil coke qui avaient bien tenu son rang
et il a fini quatrième de la saison
et là il va éliminer magnus au premier
en demi finale ou équivalent en finale
et ce qui est le premier maintenant au
classement au blitz
tu sais ça change tout le temps
dernièrement ça avait été ma caméra sans
jouer est là depuis le dernier grand
duché sourds j'imagine que c'est
toujours un haka murat non parce qu'il a
fait moi tout ce que je peux te dire
parce qu'en fait tu sais que le site
2007 point comme sur l'europe en russie
il interdit je sais pas monsieur souvent
pas et d'ailleurs ayem doigts glissent
raconte je suis en train de regarder
enfin au cocon quoi le site 2007 souvent
pas la russie pour que les sponsors
d'opérer qui ne voient pas que il ne
faut pas être battu le top 10 c'est
nakamura numéro un mondial en blitz
deuxième carlson troisième quart jaeckin
et maxime et que 16e mais ce classement
c'est n'importe quel est troisième au
criquet nomade mais ça n'a pas d'autres
le cirque 2007 voit souvent
mais c'est n'importe quoi c'était à ce
moment de blitz en fait tu fais un bon
tournoi tu gagnes 150 points tu fais un
mauvais ton père 150 plus totale à jour
des infos en soirée blitz et j'aurai un
terreau d'un top 10 si tu veux
contrairement à c'est moi qui vais
rentrer dans le top 10 j'ai mis un peu
et on rapide c'est magnus numéro un
mondial maxime numéro 2 et n'a qu'à
numéro 3 et korobov numéro 4 bah ouais
bien sûr tu sais que c'est mon manque de
famille le nom de famille de mauvais je
serai pas c'est pour ça que c'est normal
et en classique
maxime numéro 4 rich numéro 5 a quand
même un round 6 j'ai l'impression que
gris chaud que l'un des très rares jours
au cours de toute l'histoire de gagner
des points en chine je pense que tout le
monde
le poste qu'il briguait ya qu un seul
joueur qui gagne deux points
de wall ag est ce que tu penses que les
carreaux est encore performant il
pourrait de redevenir champion du monde
ou faire devenir championne à la seule
condition les plus d'ailleurs facilement
devenir champion du monde dans la seule
condition que l'on m'accuse termine ce
jour dans un asile et ils pensent qu'il
pourrait revenir dans ce cas là ils
reviennent en force comme amanda frais
une fois kasparov en partie parce que
sinon kasparov kaka pendant des années
en alsace on s'ouvre à jean yanne
somalienne qu'est-ce qu'on va partir de
2005 par 2006 à nantes ce plan dimanche
email mois et donc n'a qu'a donc les
lieux faire son amende avec le stock
d'invendus pas grand chose
le temps est autorisé de comment dire
accélérer le procès de l'otan se
retrouvent dans un asile en espérant sur
maxime
oui mais c'est ce extraordinaire quand
même je dois dire jouait dans de grandes
croix par laurent hallé rapidité de
décrire il puis de prendre son temps
maintenant fuld ou au fusain ou d'angers
3 ou jeu parfois parce qu'on fait rire
plus de coups normaux
il n'y a plus rien et il se retrouve
dans une telle prise il ya plus de coups
normaux
maintenant n'importe quel coup on peut
appeler en cours avant gardiste en cours
ou futuriste un goût bizarre un couple
pervers parce qu'il ya plus de coups
normaux juste fosse 2 mais c'est ça on
verra bien demain et la bonté quoi de
l'autre côté hockey c'est sûr qu'ils
sont au départ h5 mais je suis
complètement mis en pl est ce qu'on vous
dit tous les comploteurs blisstree mais
du coup est ce que tu penses que fiat
500 un excellent coup de maxime pour
servir ce que je vois maintenant
parigot c'est bien ça paraît que d'une
autre voie la position de max a joué
dans ces formations là parce qu'à
puissant que jamais traversé mon esprit
mon après avoir joué six mois il est
vrai je suis comme l'adoption
oui on l'a écouté
mais c'est bien trop profond trop
profond dans beaucoup de comédies
dorfman à la peau
mais pourquoi pourquoi pas fou juin le
tour
donc maintenant il veut faire alors la
via dolorosa quoi je crois
h3 parle de g4 savait tous qu'il en
compte quand est-ce qu'on sortira las
les fichiers ppt et gêne dans quelques
semaines
b tous on va attendre on va passer noël
et tout ça pour pas qu'il soit partagé
puis après après les fêtes et le nouvel
ambassadeur les pgm je prends une ces
questions mais l'épée gêne tout le monde
allait partager parce que pour répondre
à bétous mais y'aura pas toutes les
analyses dessus 9 donc ok maintenant au
moins un caennais les finalement on
connaît les deux prochains coups d'eau
magnus ce jeu 3-3 qu'est ce que les
noirs peuvent et doivent organiser en
attendant souvent mes chers amis
une telle manière qu'on 400 cavaliers
car c'est une faute parce que font ces
quatre touchés car après tout ce n'est
pas d'être une réussite parce que le
foot c'est toujours bloqué par le
parlement et le pire par les pions
d'ailleurs d'où la popularité de cette
formation au qatar et 3 parce que ça
donne de la solidité au blanc et donc
avec à une telle forteresse 60 les
besoins alors peuvent se permettre
la tacle souvient notamment je suis
resté cinq ans mais c'est sur moi contre
sela qui a été visé le coude en tête
d'un pont
parce que je joue donc eu décollé de
saint côme i soler faut fouiller 5
ok peu importe je jouais alors est ce
que je connaissais tout citoyen à tour
ces trois ou six comme le sceptre que
trois courses et trois à tancer par
efficace que la réunion prend et cavalli
prendre des 5
ouais donc tour ces trois intermédiaires
et ce bon donc ça marche pas juste je
suis aussi prendre g 6e 6 6 et 3
peu importe je garde du mois tous sont
en hausse à tiassalé de machiavélique
dans ce 3e set je 4 je crois pas
vraiment mais qui sait avec les 200
mesures par exemple le foot soit je sais
finalement ils jouent ce petit tour et
ça se termine avec le choc devant ce
drame aux huit matchs avec les loges les
symphony des cases noires fait donc
peut-être se salir son intérieur si
comme à l'est de s'emparer pour prouve
que les cinq ans ça c'est sûr et est un
problème donc maintenant peut-être
encore un petit peu mieux sa manière
quoique je crois tu as we tiendront
affiche 2,5 milliards d'euros écrit je
l'aï dit ajay owen objets et dans ce cas
là où j'habite seul vous profond profond
profond profonde et même convaincant
d'accord donc je change mon avis c'est
toujours de cela je vais essayer de
réagir différemment mais ce que tu peux
cacher ce que ledit l'ordinateur s'il te
plait je tentais moi moi je veux tester
mon donc un sac quand les cinq verges et
trois doigts toujours été un mauvais je
suppose
pour les mêmes raisons si on prend fou
prend ok mais attends je définis en fait
tout bête pions grand fou prend ou
éprise prises et maintenant vous sert
bien sûr des gens qui m'ont convoquée et
kavala en grèce 1 400 à voir sans se
voir sacrifier quoi que ce soit oui ça
sent quand même que je joue pas depuis
tous trois en 2000 je m'appelle on en
boit
oui oui c'est bien ça l'aidait donc
comment lorsque mieux préparé ça est-ce
qu'il est noir peuvent se permettre un
truc con car il existe je sens que je
suppose que livre de sand
n'est ce pas ici de des d'un v6 il se
voit pas de mesures punitives étudie 1,5
pour lui sur un luxueux que les deux
centres étaient entre 6 et je vois pas
comment ce que depuis mieux donc par
essence il y en a de tlm en oeuvre comme
cavaliere le 3 mai ça existe des choses
bonjour canadiens 5 way par exemple
cette yamaha de tel truc qu on peut
passe
oui ta meuf de marsan mandat mais il ya
plus de dance 3 way est maintenant
double bonbons d'halloween et s'il
encaisse b6 au soleil désolé bien sûr
vous ne fonctionne qu'après sa manche
est déjà intense et assurer encore dame
ces quatre noms que les 10 les habitudes
de ce très bien d'habitude c'est la
plupart des cas ce trio un ici on sait
que ça va être autre chose n'est donc
qu'un v6 à ce mauvais côtés alors parce
que par exemple que les pétoires mais
pourquoi est-ce que je suis tellement
timide et je joue comme le précise
barclays au sein je garde toujours le
sur cinq est maintenant pousser un fossé
un matin il a joué il a joué dans cette
caisse un ordre de coups pas idiot et
garde la fesci car la flexibilité avec
lecavalier il mais la dame bien mais si
jamais il ya plus de trois ans qu'est
mode de terrain peut pas garder tout les
possibles de l'été quoi bon ok dans ce
set
maintenant à toi
tandis que j'ai 4 direct ça peut pas
marcher mais n'ont donc pas la page par
toi parce que 6 h quatre fous je sois tu
dois prouver quand même que vous passez
pour le pion à hay adams cinq fois 4e
simple je suppose
tiens d'ailleurs 6h ou que vos livres 5
comme jean foule de la dame parmi les
tables de plus marrant que je veux damas
n'a bougé trois dames gère faugère d'un
machin mais les mots rappelait à mais je
pense que si elles venger de l menaces
kendall en f4 non tu dois quand même
faire foucher 3,6 d'un mercato je fous 3
et urbain
j'aimais ça est-ce que ça peut valoir
une tour un tel truc je pense pas non
ouais je sais pas mais je n'ai rien à
dire je sais pas qui tu peux
éventuellement faire mal à rallier
bouffe ça et revenir oui oui
non ma faute at compensation parce que
la dame trop bizarre ce cp totale à
terme le plus besoin que jamais et moi
je me livre de demain donc h34 plutôt
non comme plutôt non sinon il vit aux
allergies 4 et les questions maintenant
est ce qu est quelque chose de concret
après disons core i5
par exemple j'ai créé quatre bourgs
bouffe est ce qu'il ya des trucs on
croit lire 3 ou j'sais pas quoi parce
que de cette position là sont toujours
riches de telle possibilité
truc c'est la grande leçon inconvénient
ce qu'elle protège pas ses deux camps
même nom oui mais je vous parle d'un
temps pour l'instant ce bond est
tant que le contrôle avec le coglais sur
des cas au québec faire cavalier 3 oui
prendre doivent prendre ici ajoie sur le
fait que les trois reprises ouais mais
j'ai d'autres 3 mai sur 15 ans et 3 à
tour pointue contre attaque la dame il
se doit pas se fier s'il faut aussi que
les 2,4 ça doit pas suffire
donc comme un point hockey par exemple
donc on s'intéressera je crois que le 5e
jeu qu'à la téloche
je pense qu'il a pu analyser carlson qui
avec la dame un aileron bien il était
blanc des papas sibilli disons qu une
telle équipe il est tellement bon goût
et même en plus il est quand même aussi
très expérimenté de jouer le toujours
les siciliens différentes bailleurs et
cela il se remit de jouer un match
d'hommes c'est donc il est possible qu
il m s'il n'est pas au courant de cet
ordre de coûts exactement où il est
peut-être très au courant des idées quoi
donc de 7 des eaux d autres peuvent
avoir plus tard et sur quatre il veut
prendre alors que les c4 s'est vite ce
soir parce que c'est toujours morose
dans ce cadre je sais je suis moi même
sens je sans toi tu mets ton puis en
surgissent même ça c'est toujours
mauvais et d'une fois et tu peux jouer
ce soir je suis d'habitude juste
écrasant donc après h3 il doit donc nous
montrer qu est ce qu il veut de de
sérieux mais tu penses qui est mieux qui
mieux je pas émettre dans ce set je prie
aime est dans ce set donc il est
possible que le besogneux mais dans ce
set je sais pas
je sens pas - quoique qu'est ce que je
comprends de l'opposition ne serait ce
que tu as déjà joué la nage de bons
parce que des visages pe non je joue à
qu'ajouter gosse et j'ai joué car je me
suis préparé pour nous mon premier
championnat de france 2006 parce que je
pensais que si je rêve +3 et mes
concurrents +3 peut-être de savoir aller
dans les départage avant je pensais que
pirates des situations que j'ai besoin
de quelque chose comme âge d'or donc
j'ai réfléchi méconnaissance et je
jouais point des parties d'entraînement
avec les noirs contre morlaàs dans ta
cuisine à moscou peut-être lamenter mais
peut-être quatre où cinq soirées comme
ça je t'ai impression on est abattu mais
retard j'étais impressionné c'est normal
ça sur age iii lp pour actions que
l'ordi kif des 5
merci ah oui parce que maintenant notre
idée avec les blancs elle marque doux
ok parce qu'evra pseudo parce qu'il
frappe c'est dans au moins deux frappes
loge de mariscal afin de concevoir et
aussi bien pour le voir au coeur de
quartier pour mieux connaître en font
que les femmes font
ok je veux faire un coup à la halle à
comment s'appelle alami qui foutent de
meetic soit 5.4 j'ai pas je veux jouer
les cases mais qui quand il avait joué
un match à 15 heures ah oui encore 2011
finalement ça se terminait avec muse
moyens
je veux gagner je donne rien mais j'ai
pas réussi mais il est pas mal non vie
qui il est pas mal et c'est ce qui est
marrant pour moi qui l'ait a
l'impression d'être hyper friendly est
profonde et je commençais du bien bel
hommage et en a commencé le match prenne
qui d'ailleurs c'était le match franck
liquori mais s'était classé non c'était
pas casser cette image rapide et on a
commencé le match jusqu'au bout et
généreux il arrêter de me parler
complètement
il répète demain celui de ma part les
machins une fois et l'église est de
nouveau mis qui est devenu friendly
aller pour que je pensais que ce bizarre
maintenant je sais que c'est la grosse
casse toi tu fais pareil
bien sûr pourquoi fredrik ou que tu veux
quoi freiner
quelle franchise quoi ya pas de principe
entre le vainqueur et le perdant
donc en fait ce que je te dise ça te
plaît ou pas défendre le bio h
et puis après fait de ton fou un petit
jouet voix
en fait j'ai le panier trop sérieusement
à fait mais bon peut-être pour ça qu il
faut ce qu'il faut c'est plus sérieux
que je pense quoi qui si fort et si ce
nom fortis parce qu'ils n'avaient pas je
fonce 3-1 veut pas jouer ces trois noms
plus fous ses trois enfants tous ces si
grave
ici je pense n'importe qui qui gagne
c'est même pas avantage c'est bien tu
rentres de partout et surtout pas bosser
ça 4 mais est-ce que maxime est pas
mieux non non je pense que cela prend
toujours autour de l'égalité juste la
façon de boire de traiter ça a été le
mot bizarre qui ont même dur de trouver
les coûts proposés les coûts parce que
une fois et leur faire accroire d'amore
tout devenu bizarre il ya plus de
logique normal qu'ils fonction donc
malheureusement pour doper le joueur
chez moi qui comme moi il faut réfléchir
mais j'aurais essayé quand même une
chose je sais que d'habitude un dégoût
2 3 n'a pas trop dans le vif non mais ce
que tu vas faire toucher par camaïeu 5 à
régler et parce que comme quoi finir oui
mais par contre le prince doit être
défendu d'un côté de l'autre côté de 5
n'est pas stoppée vraiment parce que les
commandes fermes et et si je fais j'ai
trois peut-être se tenait aux farceurs
aux 2e 3e 1er mai j'ai une idée je veux
ramener la tour je veux continuer vous
tous je dis je d'un tour d2 c'est
sûrement pour être nul mais ouah ouah
non mais c'est pour continuer dans
l'idée quoi extraordinaire chapeau
messieurs chapeau c'est quoi être nul
n'en sait qu exceptionnellement c'est
pas moins bien que ce que je proposais
je pense objectivement mais et ça vaut
au hameau des 5es juste 20 ans
à défaut f4 un moment donné ok voici dix
ans par sa connaissance des 5 x 3 2 513
de fausses preuves mais arnaud nomme se
doper
qu'est ce que je suis ce sens qu'elle
recommence on te fuis pas je voulais
faire çà çà çà çà çà non après dans ce
tournoi mais il ya x 3
poule 5 peut-être juste rock folk you go
avocat mais son poteau d'un moteur donc
à juste mon entrée surprise il y avait
une idée marrante c'était faux mais deux
échecs féminin ouais c'est au choix tous
donc ça marche pas du tout mais après on
sent qu'il ya d'autres coûts sociaux
qu'elle
qui t'as voulu fouache 3 mais ça n'a pas
marché je leur dis pas perdre trop de
temps surtout que je sais pas si ça joue
pas qu'elle en dise il faut h3 ton cou
est reconnaissant j'avais peur de trucs
machins sur ces deux mais si ça marche
ou qui selon l'ordinateur ça marche
donc bravo killing g3 l'aider c'est pas
faux h3 quoi qu un jour peut-être force
3 monts ac d'ailleurs une fois la tam
partir de d2 où ils auraient pu être
touchés par les c4 force 3.6 peut-être
parfois quoique qui je crois pas ok donc
peut-être les 17 h 30 km autour de 21.4
conseils de nos mères six films ma part
mon collègue
non mais c'est joli g3 et vous c'est
peut-être très fin tu sais je sais pas
objective parce que j'ai un groupe
grosse tendance d'un match 3 partout
même ici donc avant tout je crois pas de
joie pour être d'autres coups parce
qu'il n'y a pas de bon casse pour la
gagne pour la tour t1 pour la tour g1
bonne case achat n'est peut-être pas
aujourd'hui donc phocéen
quoique peut-être un peu fou sans logis
mais n'empêche s'arrête pas de cinq ans
mais je pense que maxime vraiment la
gagner c'est là bas dans ce cas là donc
un pur s'est félicité du premier but de
la partie au moins un peu constaté déjà
que ça aurait pu être pire et s'en
inquiètent bien bien bien pires et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont de si nous tous
donc déjà séparément elles ce principal
donc soif ou sera soit je crois photo
non voilà donc un accueil beaucoup en
nombre
entend des bruits coup c'est juste qu'on
à l'autre partie qui se joue en même
temps et qui va finir sur une news qui
agissent 3 g 8 a mis six cavaliers ici
je vais vite cavani a réussi sur walf 8
à 9 7 euros ça est donc nulle dans le
parti déjà mais c'est bien pour un run
yann qui avoir récupéré de ses problèmes
respiratoires ce qu'il a annulé le
prochain tournoi pour cause de maladie
des piqûres de l'ong
c'est pas un endroit sur la planète
terre où tu voir lorsque tu as des
problèmes respiratoires
je pense que c'est plutôt can la côte
d'azur en général ou qui voit dans une
telle situation oui mais ce n'est
sûrement pas londres
je sais parce que toute ma jeunesse j'ai
souffert de problèmes restent avec les à
londres toi un petit moment
j'ai vécu mais à cette époque que je ne
veux plus de tes problèmes et j'en avais
pas sinon je sais qu'il ya des télés un
gros à colombes avec le climat très
froid et humide et très humide présumer
que tu vois pas parce que c'est cette
indifférence
il y aller je vois pas jérusalem j'ai
piscine bas je pense que elle est
passible que juste il est moi jouer
d'autres dernière deux printemps
approchant j'ai bien aimé mon takam
signa un contrat dit tu prends un demi
million d'euros par an d'honoraires tu
peux non je ne sais pas je trouve ça un
peu
bien que moi qui trouve sa spéciale ou
moi tu sais ce que j'aurais fait
j'aurais juste puni quoi interdit de
jouer le prochain cycle ou pas de toute
manière il n'y a pas que toi qui pensent
qu'il ya bien trop de super tournoi que
et que ses jambes
parfois on a l'impression que jour pas
chaque semaine juste tous les jours on a
cette impression de la peine
il vient de terminer un tournoi puis 2e
3e 4e rien attendre bien sûr donc à un
moment donné
la même force de voir les problèmes
respiratoires leur problème est forcé
d'avoir des problèmes de jeu par quoi je
parle de grille oui donc des pôles et le
troisième avait une crise de mayonnaise
et la quatrième on sait de quelle crise
là mais on veut pas le dire c'était pour
rire il chose que moi les crises la
crise de lehman est écrit de jeu c'est
pas cru je sais pas je sais pas quoi en
fait je sais très bien à quoi sert il
avait juste plus assez de chemise
donc même si ça a joué j'en profite pour
remercier tous les gens qui suivent ce
tronc avec nous oh ouais ça nous fait
plaisir que vous êtes toujours aussi
nombreux que ça parce que pas tout le
monde peut se vanter d'une telle
popularité
non malheureusement oui donc ça c'est
agréable
4 kills qui dit merci à vlad dans le
cerveau est ce que tu vas sortir un
livre prochainement vlad au foie
certains me parlent livre une série de
vidéos consacrées à la vie à l'école
soviétique relève ton téléphone que je
fasse va tous tombés parce que là on est
mal parti en gros black il est mieux
chez moi il ya
il ya quatre cinq jours là maintenant
pour filmer la deuxième partie est en
gros il est venu avec ce dossier et
c'est que le groupe sait que une partie
du dossier et il ya des notes de partout
des articles de journaux des machins
enfin il ya tout un tas de trucs et en
gros tout ça c'est sûr l'école
soviétique et on a même un deuxième
papier du coup avec le plan de la série
de vidéos mais ça va être extraordinaire
peut-être ça va être la série de vidéos
est entre guillemets livre qui fera le
plus progressé en français c'est
vraiment incroyable mais juste c'est
tellement dur est lourd à faire qu'on
sait pas quand ce sera fini je sais même
pas si on aura fini en 2020 tellement le
travail
ouais normal moi sur le point qui est
faux de a voiture on doit terminer vers
la fin de 2020
on espère ouais on espère et on a on a
filmé le teaser du coloriste pas si on
peut le madère cette introduction
c'est quoi les poils ce métier que
l'école soviétique sociaux en appelle
forcément parfois les coups et les
russes c'est faux les chorus n'existe
pas vraiment
l'une de ces courses 8 x a fait une
partie de l'école soviétique les
politiques à exister
normalement à partir de l'année 19 ans
et jusqu'à l'âme 19,91 donc ça ferait si
je me trompe à 75 ans et à partir de là
naît 19 48 qu'en bobigny qui a été
couronnée par le titre de champion du
monde
cette école-là à l'hégémonie mondiale
pendant 24 heures avant le match
fischer spassky à reykjavik 19,72 donc
24 ans de domination totale
mais une fois réfléchir ce clip c'est
donc de nouveaux revenus l'hégémonie
total à voir donc avoir la chute de
l'union soviétique parce que caster est
en cours
lolo comme les deux produits d'école
soviétique
oui et pour quand même en conclure
n'oublions pas qu'il soit maxime vachier
lagrave soit etienne bacrot soit je le
bottier soir la fraîcheur soir marine
oskarsson soit fabiano caruana ou à nous
dire ce sont tous les produits de la
course mythique
parce que les livres soviétique
les entraîneurs et critique dans le cas
de maxime perez ce qui dans le cas des
étiers nikitine par ashlee et les autres
dans le cadre de jeu et le boitier je
pense qu'une dizaine de taupo jour ce
mythique y compris progrès skis qui a
vécu à paris pendant longtemps
donc en fait tous les mythes tout ce qui
est du milliard du taux poser chaque
matin ces restes joueurs le produit de
l'école soviétique parce que c'était une
loi fondatrice voir et avalé d'écrire au
cours de du travail empirique pendant
elle s'arrête là ou bien ils ont malgré
une hyper elle a en même temps donc
maintenir ce toujours pas comment
répondre à ce petit à petit chaque
touche tu m'as sur ce dont je le
comprends qu'ils viennent a déjà une
réponse mais les réponses trop peut-être
pour étoffer ce moment peut-être assez
propose une petite pause
tu faire une petite pause web une petite
juste une petite pause 5 minutes ouais
alors attends moi ce que je propose à
temps il faut que je fasse je n'avais
pas j'avais pas prévu les pauses en fait
tu vois pas ce que j'ai appris pas mal
de choses minuscules
non mais je vais faire une pause mais
juste il faut que je fasse un petit truc
pour que pour qu'on puisse faire la
pause sur ces belles paroles
en fait comme on regarde la partie de
magnus j'ai bien envie de mettre pas
groupe contre m'amuse pendant la pause
ça fait longtemps que je n'ai pas misé
donc pourquoi pas non mais il faut que
la trouve
et que je la mette c'est possible je
suis en train de faire ça du coup à tac
tac tac on va faire à temps mad studios
du qu'on va rester comme ça on va faire
vidéo et comme ça on mettra une petite
pub
j'aime bien tu es très heureux de la pub
non comme non pas aux rugueux les nîmois
de petites pages de pub une petite pause
s'impose à taq taq taq
ah ouais on va bloquer ça bon du coup
les mecs on se retrouve dans six sept
minutes pour la suite de la partie n'est
pas que moi s'il vous plaît ne partez
pas apte au dessus à tout de suite quand
vlad tu peux tu peux déjà y aller je
lance je lance tout ce qu'il faut lancer
et on se retrouve donc j'en suis une
longue pub
malheureusement ne partez pas et la
vidéo
magnus au sto c'était horrible ok j'ai
car boom tu dégages
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] g premier la
grotte on a beau faire des 4,3 tout le
tournoi
g4 on avait dit qu'on ferait je suis en
lannister je tiens parole au quai des
cinq sujets de tu dégages
ok tu commences à te jure ce truc là oui
ok j'ai 5 la taxe pike e5 des quatre
jeux med si tu regardes ce truc là en
replay c'est total dédicace à toi tonton
dédicace à m dédicace à mai de la
famille ok c 4
justin assez incroyable tu sais qu'on
dirait qu'il fait en train de jouer
c'est juste ouf
je suis juste en pls c'est pas plutôt un
jeu contre le champion du monde d'échecs
là quand même sa première fois dans ma
vie
bon ok les erreurs qu'on a fait c'est
prendre et 5 par le passé et je pense
qu'on voulait faire dam des trois assez
souvent
donc c'est ce qu'on va faire c'est i
rocks ne joue pas mal de gamins donc
j'ai envie de faire h4 et d'aller faire
cavalier h3 et fouet f4
ok il veut faire cavalier b4 ça on va
lui interdire on va faire à trois on va
mettre le cavalier en achevant va jouer
fouet f4
pottier les mecs pensent qu'il prépare
un sale coup je pense qu'il veut prendre
rendez-vous aussi se moquer c'est pas si
grave si prend prend fou aussi ceux qui
on va mettre la dame là c'est pas si
grave affaire cavaliers affichent 3 on
s'en fout aussi fait des seins je le
fais c'est simple je m'en fous total est
ok s'il fait ça ce qui a préparé depuis
longtemps maintenant on va lui faire
c'est simple et on va essayer de lui
jouer à la main us en fait je veux dire
que son cavalier à six est mal placée ok
mais on va start et par damas 4 il va
faire dame c8 on va faire des quatre et
on va continuer à jouer sur son cavale
qui est très mal placé et peut-être
après je ferai même cavalier prend 2,3
et fouet ok on va faire des cartons
protège notre pions en fait on est bien
ok prise je prends de b évidemment et
maintenant je veux juste être ok je vais
encaissé une fois attendait mais là ya
peut-être un pur ans et 6 qui traînent
quoi d'un côté on va prendre one time et
on va faire trois mois les mecs je pense
qu'on est bien parce qu'on menace fait
fort en fait et je pensais juste très
très bien en fait faut juste faire le
vide dans la tête on joue contre un mec
lambda on va lui défoncer sa mère désolé
pour le langage mais ok je me motive
comme je peux ok tours à huit dont qui
prépare cavaliers b8 mais je prends son
fiancé 6 certains français si sa foi
simple
dans le français 6 x 5 [ __ ] j'ai pas
le temps tous des fonds [ __ ] c'est pas
manu soit un karl scène pour rien sinon
dame français si ça gagne juste quoi est
ok c'est impossible de faire marcher ça
ok on reste calme
on fait fou d2 on développe et tours b 1
je prends la colonne un cavalier à deux
cavaliers bécade [ __ ] fabien le plan
de fabien m'a déjà parlé de sa cavale et
a2 cavalli b4 c'était dans le title
tuesday dans un title fusée préfet
précédent ok il veut faire ça mon fou
est mal placé mais de façon il n'empêche
qu'ils avalaient à doké et b4 quelque
part je sais plus quoi faire
j'ai plus le mojo là
goethe être placé mon roi verser 2 ça je
suis pas sur l'espion là qui va être
mauvais
ok
en train de s'en tirer quoi mais
cavalivi ce qu'il a bien sauvé le truc
en train de nous menacer là ok on aura
malheureusement montré la grand beau
champion du monde quand même
mais a le plus on est vieux qui va
rester en prise il aura bien trouvé le
tour à 8 j'étais pas loin de défoncer
quand même j'étais pas loin quoi bon
aller on reste concentré ok ils menacent
ça il faut protéger il faut 1 c'était
l'idée de base
si je fais cavale f4
ok je suis complètement ouf je rentre
dans une grande technique contre magnus
on n'a pas peur ok j'ai calculé jusqu'à
calais français pour penser cette dame
prend un sens les mecs j'ai vu ça jusque
là et je me suis que sa tour pouvait pas
être dans la merde
après l'action prend ici aussi question
moi qui aime on n'est juste pas mal
encore je rangeais absent je vais les
meilleurs échec de ma vie quoi
je juge jamais joué comme ça c'est vous
qui regardent confiance on a joué la
tour en f1 fait juste une bonne partie
pour le moment mais comme ça on mena
sera peut-être fou aux six dames prend
d'un prend et tous réfutent mat
ok su faire un truc qui va vous paraître
dingue je vais pas prendre son cavale et
c'est peut-être un crack avis
j'étais juste de craquer
[ __ ] j'ai pas vu assez loin [ __ ]
j'ai pas vu assez loin un fichier
juste en aura été bien content magnus
quand même
il veut obtenir la casse des cinq sont
cavale et il va menacer cavale b4 il
replace la dame sans 4 secondes
je tiens tout maintenant foire et
l'enflure b2 je tire encore pouvait 2
j'avais pas vu je suis encore en vie
quoi c'est un miracle et gdf cet hymne à
ce qu'il voit bien il va prendre en b2c
obligé
c'est juste complètement gagnant il
objet de prendre b2 est ok c'est juste
complètement gagnant bon maintenant il
faut pas de choc ce qui va pas être le
plus évident [ __ ]
juste arraché en train de de choc les
mecs
je suis juste en train de choc contre
magnus carlsen
quand je suis déconnecté liasse on a
fait nul contre marseille on a fait du
conteur scène
[Musique]
booth est juste ou non les mecs
voilà près des bons souvenirs surtout
pour moi ou pour toi aussi d'ailleurs
non bien sûr
c'était une belle partie pour le monde
chacun c'est beau c'est beau souvenir
retour à la partie et il a joué blad
bouger 3
d'ailleurs pendant la pause j'ai eu le
temps de vérifier qu est ce que ça donne
en te vois pas du continent j'ai vérifié
qu'est ce que ça donne et l'ordinateur
n'aime pas du tout les propositions
positionnelle de qui viennent parce que
qu après eux deux quand il est de 5 200
jeudi décollé de sang que les dessins
faut 2,5 fourcade bien sûr par le 5 mai
la damb au jeu peu importe
bassett b 6 à 7 partout les noirs sont
mille et une choses sinon sur
l'ordinateur
comme quoi une répétition n'a été
possible si au lieu de je crois au
maquis où se réfugient cinq dames 5 fu
trois fois pendant deux sets
parce que après forget 5,2 5,6 en fait
foi
4 par exemple le 5 est peut-être trop
fort ici parce que je dois à peut-être
au lieu 2 fois 4 x 4 km 2,5
disons que valait 5 d'argent ici aux
moines le pire n'est pas en prison
est ce que veut dire que peut-être la
dame sur joe va être si le pire n'est
pas une prise en prison juste
sympathique je vais te prêter votre four
3 damage du collège 7 euros à bouche
tous les cinq avaient campé avec une
compensation de ça c'est intéressant
comme variante ouais c'était intéressant
donc mr ils apprécieraient de suivre
mais donne des bonnes idées
donc maintenant on peut constater que
magnus
à troyes et de louis alphonse giro 2010
bof rythme qu'avant board pour les
raisons qu'on a vu juste
pour des raisons que je viens de voir ça
a été intéressante d'ailleurs mon cher
ami fougeux 5 dans ce sens cash 4
c'était intéressant mais il a fait des
cinq chang'e 3 les gardois
parce que selon l'ordinateur dès que les
dessins que les 2 500 que c'est un
avantage mais toi net mais ça semble
assez logique nom des cinq bien sûr le
décor
de toute manière le der doit être fait
de sa collègue de 5-fu 2,5 et juste au
port d'owendo plus en pour le voit
parfois c'est pas si bien d'être aussi
compétitive non mais c'est cool en plus
si c'est maxime qui fait tomber le
l'invincibilité et qui laissent leurs
corps à thiviers ac parce que j'ai pas
aimé un tweet de magnus en fait
qu'est-ce que les écrits en fait il
allait faire ses parties en ligne
norvégienne n'a contre des joueurs à
2003 et il arrêter avec le soutien aux
personnes
ouais il a dit qu'il veut pas qu'on
compte et c'est parti là because i to be
too tibia caisse quoi a d'ailleurs ou ce
qu était vécu ce matin je sais pas mais
j'ai pas trop aimé tweet il joue
maintenant à los payos championnat du
kazakhstan rapide le matin d'un bilan
dans le cadre accents rien il est devenu
khattak
non mais peut-être c'est un championnat
d'écossé open quoi parfois qu'il mention
voit ses messages où on les voit mais
oui mais dans mes excuses ont été
coupées ah ouais donc il est il est il a
utilisé le terme tv casque mais juste je
mets enquêtes qu'il a menées et iveco
au fait ce record je sais plus je les
lui mais je sais plus non mais en gros
pourquoi pas on faisait rien de mal mais
juste j'ai pas trop aimé du coup
j'aimerais bien que ils réussissent pas
à battre le record du tibia caf ou un
jour si via qu'est-ce qui vient casque
mais qui aujourd'hui donc il termine sa
série le rendement il essaie de se
rattraper et keep on perd encore que et
maxime devient 3e ou le dire pas trop
petit wiacker façon twitter je suis
heureux dans mon record
nate mc du cesc la crise et on me dit
que c'est un placement de pièces bien
trop magnus est et dites moi chers
spectateurs
qu'est ce qu'un général vous aimez cette
guerre de tweets à dakar ces niches par
exemple qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
qui est écrit par exemple non mais quand
centre de moi j'ai mon point de vue ou
sur ceux qui ont écrit car c'est ce que
crient à nice que qui écrivent les
autres moi je pense que carson souvent
c'est marrant par contre je pense que ce
qui est écrit grise d'aujourd'hui
jusqu'au jour ne le sait manier c'est
marrant c'est avec toi sinon de la part
de grease souvent c'est une tentative de
blague mais c'est les blagues tellement
riche
comment dire en français ne tient pas
comment dire ça aux quelques trogi quoi
mais par un shérif steve blake de merde
en fait fin c'est aujourd'hui le coi
conquois qui bosse des maths brousse
tu t'attendais pas à ça - c'est pourquoi
les ennemis sont les coins non mais je
ne sais pas en fait c est moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils assument vers soignies
de toi deux fois il veut france info oui
et alors elle aurait quoi faire avec
tous les enfants
klitscho mangerait pas dit que c'est dit
qui chante je pense que ce n'est pas qui
je pense qu'une quiche ses critiques à
belmont - ce matin là c'est même pas qui
c'est pire que tout non mais oh mon dieu
il lâché 4 ans ils se votent pas jamais
méchant au contraire mais il est piquant
mais comment dire disons que je pense
que dans la proche de guiry et de se
moquer de tout le monde et de vouloir
être qui courait blessant mais prends
toi z'en grande chez ce tour si tu es si
courageux je veux dire que j'aime bien
l'humour piquant et méchant on quand il
est subversif mais là c'est pas super
siffler algérie s'en prend à qui il s'en
prend qu à des mecs qui peuvent rien lui
faire mais dit que le grand chef sur ce
poste
je pense que c'est papy qu'un je pense
que ce humoristique mais il est vrai que
c'est méchant mais ce que j'aime pas
c'est que si ces méchants envers les
autres joueurs prends-toi des mecs plus
fort que toi
du coup j'accepte et j'excuse parce que
c'est courageux mais là ok quand tu as
fait une blague sur magnus de blagues
sur aronian et trois blagues sur mvele
mais tu t'es dit que tu étais un mec
solide mais tu t'en es prix qui a des
mecs qui pouvait rien faire trente trois
ans grant cheissoux prends toi z'en à la
fidh qu'est ce que je veux dire on va au
bout du truc quoi on y fait de l'humour
du jour n'est moins sûr f le stress je
pense tout à fait d'accord et du gens
passeraient boittiaux ausculté gens tu
veux parler de tourner ces crues scp qui
me fait toujours des réminiscences
donc oui ce que sont les joueurs qui
viennent de sa quête de jeu en fait j'ai
par madi dessin qui a été jouée genia
confirmation parce que moi je n'ai pas
sur l'échiquier en fait et est ce qu il
a fait déjà ou pas pour
nous le dira s'il vous plaît donc si
revenir en gros c'est la vache qui rit
si je comprends bien tu connais oui la
vache qui rit le fromage
amat donc a pas d'autres dessins croqués
c'est normal qu'ils hésitent encore déjà
je pense que au maximum en train de te
le dire en train de savourer les
profondes autour d'eux d'autres jeux
d'eau jeu d'autos j'ai deux et ils
pensent maintenant comment vaut mieux la
réfuter avec 2,5 immédiat ou avec 2,5
après tout je sais je les vis qui dit
pas assez battu quand il était jeune
salaires rue de l'école soviétique mais
toi tu parles pas ben tu parles c'est
pas les voir ce métier ça c'est l'art de
re toi tu parles de l'école je parle de
badoit les ronds points tenant quitte à
casser je mettais mon pote aussi
candidat met mon mieux pour mon meilleur
pote mam qui m'a fait ça c'est tombé à
petit inquiète par contre je pense que
c'est les murs de choses qui il aurait
pu en faire ce que je te dis mais pas ce
que c'est un poste que l'autorisé ça ma
radio aussi sage que maintenant tu
abuses et ray ban creux
malheureusement j'aurais peur de rien et
depuis j'ai appris qu'est ce que c'est
des terrains frileux mais c'était dans
un billard n'ont pas questionner pas
raconter non c'est sait pas que c'est
désagréable moi c'est une longue
histoire
adro à l'histoire à la con ils étaient
deux ans plus âgé que moi et c'est moi
qui l'a frappé il ya deux jours après en
avant il a eu sa bonne chose
après oui après ceux qui on m'a calmé
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours donc y
compris mais pas et j'en suis très très
content parce que pour pas mal de gens
sais c'est pas une mauvaise idée de
de prendre ça même part de tes limites
méthode drastique était resté pas tari
coupe à la main et aurait pu j'aurais pu
au moins c'était c'était impossible
c'était plus possible sa frappe était
bien trop forte
oui ça fait un peu fantastique parce que
mon nez au lieu de dire là où il est
maintenant
c'était là quelques pas des gens qui les
lie noir ou bien pris d'autres avantages
quoi l'étamine droit très bas il faisait
du vote à aa
je n'ai pris confirmation belle frappe
est avec canal c'était le printemps
87 le moment je suis donc 13/2 quoi
quelque chose comme ça mais tu as fini à
l'hôpital et toute ta mère devait
tremper ls non oui bien sûr c'est
pourquoi mais il m'a appris un truc aux
échecs peut-être un peu montré fin ouais
ok par exemple je partais 4/6 6/4 6/4
6/3 fougeux 7/4 2-6 couvrir trois petits
rentrer h3 par exemple 5 par exemple le
foudroie fait jamais ça deux des quatre
ou huit f3 avec l'épisode le plus beau
match 3 certes un peu près c'est lui qui
m'a appris ça ce que dit quasiment avant
malgré ces données et il m'a fait ça et
après je suis ce que je veux me souvenir
toute ma vie aux cavaliers sur h5 fou
sur cinq dames sur h 4 l'autre cas aux
listes qui se remet neige pas vers où la
cua c'était à refaire quand il m'a
marqué au bout du jeu par vincent caup
j'étais déjà content que ça se termine
et quoi parce que j'avais l'impression
que toutes les pièces se sont mis sur
les cases noires faible autour de mon
droit
donc depuis à chaque fois que je faisais
ça avec le noir c'était marrant pauvres
parce que je sais juste que c'est haram
ça c'est un fait à présent il ne
rentrait pas ne raterait jamais dans ces
structures depuis avec les bois quand le
pire ne surgisse toi avec h2o oui avec
eux je dois jamais sinon vos termes elle
a été cassée deux ans plus tard et il
est ivre ou encore des chèques se gare
au canada à chaque fois que je vois au
kazakhstan jeu pas il sera même pas de
grand tournoi donc je lui vois plus il
veut pas trop cassé le nez une deuxième
fois quoi tout intérêt parce que je
reviens en force
ok il a joué collet 5 6 1 ouais bon
difficile de critiquer le coup sauf que
peut-être deux ans que j'étais comme
quoi plus concret mais je veux pas
critiquer secours il n'y a pas tout
rejet de tourner et de la non forcément
de toute façon ici il a vu les mêmes
idées que toi c'est qu'on n'est pas
forcément vrai est-ce que après tout je
2 juste comme ça je peux faire que les
toits que les trois cas le câble on sera
pareils des tours des trois de nouveau
mais monsieur d'accord donc douche d'eau
à l'heure et après deux jeux d'eau mais
le problème c'est qu'ils ont avec le
cavalier sur cinq ans nettement moins
d'envié de jouer de centre oui et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs soit je le sens mais
je suis sérieux nous faut être quatre
qui arrivent et qui cloue pas juste des
je pense le carrefour quatre flotteurs
et en plus serein autour d'eux et
surtout si c'est râpé pour les 5 6 ans a
montré son genre çà çà çà çà çà faux
besoins et fourbe et ça qui est
important
les finesses de mon partenaire m'a mais
alors et au rejet des salariés
reconnaissent trois accords et cet échec
donc touche de alors s'il va le faire ce
que
votre parti l'a vraiment choqué choquée
toucher quoi donc toujours sauf que bien
sûr c'est pas encore si c'est lié à quoi
si tu fais tout ce dont on se demande
pourquoi tu commences à partir de
coquettes parce que normalement lors du
conseil du 4 mai ce soit et le terrain
pour de tels coûts donc normalement ces
points pas un bon signe ni de la
compression positionner signé au niveau
du sens de l'opposition
mais puisque hanifa qu'ils demandent
c'est un bon choix de ne pas ok pour le
joueur français
d'ailleurs je vois pas trop de problèmes
de requins maintenant pour les noirs
parce que les g4 et tout le reste c'est
bien trop long
juste oui j'irai je pense que c'est tout
à faut faisait à briser cette partie n'a
pour le moment fait un peu penser dans
l'esprit à la partie
mazet moussa aux championnats de france
à chartres gelé sur moi vu moi je me
souviens pas comment ça se déroulait au
maso a juste pas réussi à attaquer le
roi et ses faits matin à la dame il a
fait un plan aussi un peu bizarres sur
l'axé rock et déjà des mousses harju un
bosseur julie qui a fait une super
partie et qui avait la garde
excellent ce type de position avec le
noir et les excellents d'ailleurs je
pense que lagarde ressemble beaucoup à
maxime en moins fort sauf
- vous y compris parce que toujours ce
qu'est ce qui est marrant c'est que
cette semaine son nom ressemble se
ressemblent maxime maxime lagrave
lagarde c'est-à-dire sans et même
physiquement
moi je pense que les deux récents boule
bien comment s'appelle ce type là
comment s'appelle à l'époque quoi harry
potter c'est moi toute l'équipe de
france sur chaque fois que je serai
qu'est ce que vous voulez même causes
pas vos frères ricouart en russe gary
c'est arrivé le même prénom d'ailleurs
tour je dois ce droit les premières
lignes de tous leurs biens et après tour
je donne mon cher ami leurs dix jours
petit rock c'est pour dire que parfois
on n'est pas si vous pouvez prétendre
jam et rtas m'a toujours dit que j'étais
bien dans les positions chaotique 1
c'est pas chaotique quoi passer nous
fait pas comme un crs toujours de les
préliminaires et les longs préliminaires
rendre le pose vraiment pas clair les
longs préliminaires vont de la position
encore plus excitante
soyons précis qu'un reflet des
métaphores réservé des élus des
eaux-vives et soignons précieux au moins
de réveiller un pressing de murillo où
est à karachi bah vous avoue savourer en
fait à l'époque ça fait une grosse
campbell dans les échecs russe parce que
pourquoi n'y en a l'un des murs joueuse
russe un moment donné a annoncé partout
sur tous les réseaux sociaux - et mon
boyfriend
non mon mari mon mari on va publier le
livre sur gamasutra échiquier tout le
monde s'attendait
après six mois qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
sortir et c'est jamais sans wii commence
au très chic hier ischios donc il peut
vraiment commune et les deux types
d'oppositions machin est ce qu'il ya de
pire des positions et isolées reste que
j'allais dire toi le pion isolé ce béton
chapitre loi et mais le livre le jamais
sorti il sortira jamais il sortira
jamais parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
parallèle entre les deux plutôt
malheureusement pour les joueurs et je
suis heureusement vu les cadences
heureusement tuque ou est ce qu'il va
faire tout rejet d'eau qu'on nous
proposait 4 dans le chat est qu'à terme
en chiffres a fait rentrer
quoi qu'ils écrivent allemand enrichir à
mettre entre de bonnes mains
sept nouveaux pays diot est trop drôle
pour moi je peux pas juste non f4 je
pense pas que ça va bien mal cette
position non pas en faire si vous voulez
à ma connaissance compte les formations
chez bing un des six fils lorsque nous
faut est sûre de toi
le pire sera prête elle est toujours en
fonction de simple au oui parce que les
tours troyes bc4 juste quatre ans soit
même façon que c'est parce solide
donc si avec le faux sur 3 vous bouger
le cul sur f4 sait qu'elle doit avoir
quelque chose de vraiment très concret
et trop quoi sinon jamais parce que sa
fabrique tout parce que n'oublions pas
nos pions de quatre tombes tout tombe
juste au nombre même le poker dessus
vous tombe donc qu'à terme en mai les
questions se joue aux dés ce qu elle va
être aussi créatif que nous pour voir
tour jeux d'eau ou comme d'habitude
pas et donc offert un autre coup non
mais il va avoir purgé deux je pense
mais pourquoi il ne faut pas rapidement
je veux une eau propre et rien n'avance
que m il est sûrement 30 noms car
cavaler trouvait derrière le calcul est
donc de quoi il pense alors tu diras tu
pries quoi te faire [ __ ] 4 ici ouais
je sais pas ok je sais et c'est fou et
4kids admettant carré lisse et quatre
langues et 6 4 6 4
j'ai peur que les secrétaires va
soulager la pression va te dire non je
vais pas je veux que mercy pour montrer
oui et là que valait 2 3 etc devient
désagréable non parce que je commence de
dominer les quinze mois il une fois le
cavalier qui défendent ainsi qu'à saint
est partie oui c'est très dangereux ça
avec le plan sur trois très dangereux qu
avec le cancer garde à vous pour vous
permettre que tel de dider d'hôtel c'est
donc 4 by qu'auteur je suis quelqu'un
d'assez primitive de l'instance
donc je joue que relève de cette tu
protèges non je veux un truc comme
cavalier bouthillier sauf ou insistant
que tournefeuille 6/4 6/4 6/4
parce que si je reprends avec le
cavalier sur ce cas et ce toute notre
histoire mais dans ce mérite je peux
vouloir g5 aussi aux anat surtout si je
m'appelle max ouais je m'appelle max
donc je veux pas vraiment je fais
semblant même si je suis match je peux
voir donc enlève deux sets je pense que
c'est une bonne réaction contre sa mère
celle qui ont maintenant se faire
quelques secondes quoi est ce que tu
peux fermer les portes parce que le
bruit qui vient pas les deux d'ailleurs
fermés partout donc
donc oui il ya deux parties lentes 4
rapide et 4 bis et je crois que les
points c'est 3 2 1 ou 4 2 1 ça je sais
pas où je me trompe toujours mode main
avec ce parce qu'ils changent à chaque
fois les points à chaque fois c'était le
maillot pour moi de calcul et permettons
g2c vraiment logique valls et parfois tu
dis que c'est pas logique ou bizarre tu
défends ces deux et non je l'aï vécu
plus c'est jugé urgent de mon avis dans
les fouets f4 c'est vrai tu vas faire
cavaler des statuts va les chasser tu
vas être le foie m6 le cahier qui va
revenir c'est pas très logique en fait
on what you were four 4 quantité précise
qu'est ce que tu vas faire après oui
mais le problème c'est que les besoins
sont toujours dans ce stade
dans cette phase 2 de ne pas comprendre
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent vraiment se
bouger les pièces c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'ils ont librement pas réussi un
de mes formules et le portrait comme en
exemple développer leur position donc
donc monde
skip this is an par rapport à ce que la
faible ouverture
même si au début on noté c'était un bon
soir à french actor vélociraptors ce
moment-là il est bien élevé l sofa bah
écoute
ouais il est bien c'est une bonne
ouverture poli avec les origines reagan
sur fois dans cette partie
oui son dernier recours aurait pu être
différent mais d'empêcher les biens tu
sais dire que c'est l'anniversaire
d'austerlitz à jose chili 6 pts tous
malgré le fait que je suis c'est du
mauvais côté mais tu es français aussi
je sais français aussi donc je vous
félicite tous les frais directs et
centrait g
[Musique]
enfin je suis un admirateur et je suis
passionné par m'appeler au jeune homme à
cacher mais dut vous serez bien que
maxime batman minus en ce jour oui le
soleil d'austerlitz seul vrai mais
soldats c'était la phrase va dire c'est
pas les phrases je pense que c'est pas
les phrases de commentaires mais c'est
au moins ce qu'il est dit le polygone le
matin d'austerlitz dans le livre d'eau
dans le livre de tolstoï guerre et la
paix mais sa stratégie s'est il avait
gagné cette guerre là parce qu'il avait
laissé les centres de repos 1
il avait fait venir une je veux pas
mentir je me rappelle pas de titre je
veux pas mal je ne pourrais pas vous
mentir je ne veux pas dire n'importe
quoi
je sais juste que c'est l'un des
meilleurs exemples pour tout son art
même s'il ya plein d'autres exemples
pendant sa campagne italienne
donc au début de sa carrière et puis
tout le monde dit qu il a carrément pris
en tant que tacticien vit ses dernières
jours en tant que la peur lorsque tout
était terminé déjà mais il est brillant
tant que compétition quand il a essayé
de sauver l'un se battre et il a été
pris par tout le monde surtout par
talleyrand nous faut changer tout comme
souvent aurait trop de succès cependant
toujours votre successeur
que penses tu de la bérézina wrap à ce
que j'en parle se rendent ce qui vous
reste un pari sur l'école soviétique
pascal va parler de cela aussi
bizarrement 5 c'est bizarre
opacité a fait savoir par les deux
célèbres d'ailleurs tout au début de
notre série on va parler de ça peut-être
le métro en teaser oui ajoutant ce que
moi je pense qu'ils ont peut-être assez
bientôt en voir publier notre teaser de
trucs et donc vous savez ce que j'en
pense
tiens d'ailleurs on aurait souhaité
publier bientôt sous on aurait dû faire
la vidéo sur napoléon aujourd'hui bah
c'est parce que on va penser en fait un
service en plus je le savais pas ce que
tu sais je suis abonné sur twitter faire
dans mon fils je regarde souvent le fil
du jour ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
c'est intéressant fait et du coup c'est
comme ça j'ai lu ce matin de décembre
austerlitz et moi j'ai appris une autre
chose moi je pendant mon jour
d'anniversaire le 9 novembre
ok tout mon avis vous savez que c'est le
jour que le calgary est devenu champion
du monde 9 novembre 19 85
et c'est l'honneur d'avoir dansé le jour
et le cerf de neuchâtel oui ça je serai
mais ce que je savais pas ce que c'est
un jour très très très spécifique pour
l'histoire allemande
trois fois trois fois premier
l'application duo 15000 m au cours de la
première guerre mondiale
2e les creusements duke bootee nazis
mais ne paraît clair j'ai passé 19 ans 4
entre comme ça dix neuf ans que je me
rappelle plus et troisième la chute
du mur de berlin du mur de berlin et
tous les trois le 9 novembre ça je ne
veux pas ça elle elisabeth baisse qui
mois a fait noter mais moi je partage au
jour de l'anniversaire avec christophe
dugarry rock du rap on a parte je le
pense je le pense vraiment
malheureusement cher mais je jouais bien
je vais bien merci a que deux pièces
maillage à la 70 m² avec une très très
belle view sur la ville prisée par à
lille la ville brûlé par l'intérieur
seront des versions françaises brûlé par
le receveur en fait plus maintenant le
matin avant c'était bien ça ah non
c'était ça pouvait être écrit comme un
livre d'histoire plus maintenant vois tu
as préféré en fait malheureusement je
n'ai pas attaqué une fille qui travaille
dans un magasin grec à côté de chez moi
malheureusement en fait j'ai pas ses
parts hausse est deux fois je me suis
dit qu'il ya pas ok je vais repasser jeu
refaire et malheureusement les travaille
plus d'ailleurs je le regrette très
fortement une très jolie fille dans un
magasin grecque
c'est là où j'ai même si tu peux me
rendre hommage gros console wii à chaque
fois qu'on achète des olives tient
demain peut-être on passe par le marché
on demain matin voilà une ouverture avec
la stagiaire et désillusions non je
réponds pas aux questions
trop personnel mais j'ai envie de dire
c'est presque une question rhétorique
comme vous savez j'ai fait deux ans de
l'université dans les facs de
journalisme et notre prof nous nous a
dit toujours n'imposer jamais les
questions qui contient les réponses
comme une vie pour les rues de vie
poulet
ben moi il réfléchit toujours le maire
mais qu'est ce que cette cadence là j'ai
pas un peu comme pape l'elysée doit un
peu tout beau tout faire pendant ces
deux heures la cua mais qui est ce que
ce seront mes pourquoi ils nous font ce
qui est incroyable c'est que tous ses
admirateurs
dk danse classique wind kasparov en tête
chroniques y compris sont tellement
quand il ya peu les réalisateurs de tous
ces cas d'un salaire moyen me regarde
jamais en fait je pense moins une fois
en retraite
qu'est-ce qu'il joue à chaque fois à
chaque fois et je devais p2 et de prises
à chaque fois mais c'est incroyable
quand même cette hypocrisie chez les
grands jours ce qui est assez incroyable
juste juste un cran en dessous portable
ça difficile à la fois des retraités qui
commence demain quoi ah oui c'est plus
la peine de cacher que tu as toujours
une fête tient d'ailleurs un futur il
parle pas de cadence mais bien de
décadence monde demande moi j'ai des
cadences gressus moi j'ai déjà répondu
j'ai déjà répondu à la question mais on
nous demande si j'ai vu la production de
cramique d'interdire l'europe aux échecs
je vais redire ce que j'avais dit alors
l'europe et collecter leurs amis que
j'ai déjà dit que c'était idiot parce
que son argument c'est qu'il ya autant
de nuls 2 victoires et 2 défaites quand
les échecs normaux et le problème des
échecs c'est que pour les chèques soient
de nouveau populaire le problème c'est
pas à le rock mais c'est bien la cadence
parce que tu joues six heures de foot de
tennis ou quoi que ce soit à chaque fois
minimum c'est ce sera un problème qui
est du rock ou pas en fait est de toute
manière en bas avec toutes les idées
rétrogrades et interdire une rx de
revenir dans les réalités de ces dix
septième siècle mais au milieu du xviie
siècle il y en avait eu assez avec ça
elles ont donc je raccourcis à les
partis d'ailleurs oui eh bien maintenant
et rauque et maintenant donc en voie où
ira voir interdire les prises ambassades
etc etc
j'ai une idée du coup et on reviendra au
chanteur engagé si on faisait bouger la
dame d'une case en diagonale et si on
faisait bouger les fous que de 2,4
d'ailleurs vous savez c'est intéressant
pour ceux qui s'intéressent au sujet mme
ce qu'ils ont lorsqu'ils ont oscillé
pendant les cycles médiévale comme il y
avait pas d eau qui ne prient pas de
prise en pension etc
il ya interruption qui avançait que
d'une qu'un bruit les parties en étaient
très longues et donc commence à jouer en
fait tu venais chez moi dans mon château
est aussi relié aux yeux chevalier de
kevin dougherty j'sais pas quoi donc à
la fraîche à l'avant cours du tkc tu
venais trois mois plus tard et en
contenu est continuellement partie donc
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas voyez une partie de
chaises en tant qu une bataille ils ont
vu ça comme une guerre mais très longue
avec plein de bataille quoi tu es un peu
moins bien dans la position tu sais que
le mac revient dans trois mois
tu essayes de comploter tulle empoisonne
ou sur le chemin et bio je vais mettre
mon but en tant qu y est quoi t'inquiète
quoi je vais scorer quoi basse à elle à
l aller pique de guiry serait beaucoup
plus marrant ouais c'est plus ou moins
c'est plus ou moins ce que raconte
l'écrivain espagnol et perses de reverte
dans son livre l'échiquier flamand
tu parlais tout gagner ailleurs
d'ailleurs je dois vous avouer une
expérience très très intéressante
récemment je jouer aux échecs avec une
fille qui m'a conquois intéressé et je
pense que très probablement à
s'intéresser au cou et au savon et
c'était très bizarre de jouer aux échecs
avec une fille qui est intéressant parce
que ça m'a jamais vraiment donc en quoi
ça donne une autre dimension à tout à
ton intérêt au jour de chèques et à tout
le reste
après j'ai commencé dans le rouge j'ai
commencé de voir sa multi dimension quoi
est il allé se loger perdu ou plus je
gagnais perdu plusieurs parties bio et
puis j'ai gagné pas mal de fils et la
bonne technique
en quoi at the do bumba
finalement il a prévalu avoir 25 minutes
mais je perds mais après tout beau il
doit peut-être penser
kevin c'est pas bon signe pour lui voilà
suivre sophie zone est ce que c'est un
point si je crois pas trop
les figurines du ps a soutenu peuvent en
fait été patrick dubois je suis portée
tout fort ce qu'il m'intéresse pas mais
je suis à ses portes avec de pauvres et
il me raconte trois choses sur son
client qui ont malheureusement je peux
pas raconter j'ai je suis pour aider à
nous deux est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
joueuses déchets qui peuvent pas tranché
anicom quatre chefs je crois aucune non
est ce que beaucoup de choses de ce qui
peut être partagé pas il y avait deux
qui m'ont battu oui mais j'ai un regret
actuellement contre ma personne
personne n'a à l'époque il n'y avait pas
le gars et ça dépend aussi dans une
partie où des images de son parti qui
que ce soit que tout petit bateau
la salle du club bourguignon qui pourra
dire au revoir complètement arrêtée au
fait en fait vous savez juste rester moi
j'ai entendu les rumeurs qu'il va
revenir après avoir terminé ses études
cambridge pourquoi j'ai objecté surpris
d'ailleurs mais ça a été conclu a
annoncé qu'il va revenir à fait et
bizarrement pas que jose chaque mot
chaque féminin en gros il veut retrouver
sa couronne d'enlever outre sa couronne
ils vont retrouver ce chaos mais de télé
parisot parce que peut-être ça sera trop
tard
ce qui en connaît un qui revient qu'on
aimerait bien un nouvel effort est donc
de toute manière peut-être elle se rend
pas compte que faire nous renouveler
deux
[Rires]
je veux dire moi avec mon gars mais je
vais dire que peut-être se rend pas
compte que deux ans qui joue pas et ça
te prendre deux ans pour revenir et
c'est pas évident vous savez maintenant
je joue un glissé je suis pas capable de
voir des choses très simples juste dans
ses rangs pas compte qu est-ce que les
tangos kouadio de la fille est sûrement
génial donc les petites est capable de
choses et fragments elle peut faire je
pense un moment donné j'ai assisté mais
jérémy m
drôle de discussion ne permutent arboré
et iphone
c'était a pu avoir les cérémonies de
clôture de l'illiade à istanbul 2012 est
morte à sauvian but du meneur de jeu et
là je m'approche de l'est celle de
clôture est donc là je vois qu aux fans
comme ça près du mur qu'on est morte à
ce avec un verdure où j'ai réglé les
rend complètement jeu déjà bâtis ou non
au tce est extraordinaire alcine cube
poèmes originaux ainsi qu'ils sont
embellies vos beaux rôles oui oui mais
je pense que je dois encore beaucoup
travailler et que les gens connaissent
pas mortel mais j'imagine bien passé
avec les bourgeons je pense proches
jaune rouge
[Musique]
oui donc et les dix qu'il doit encore
beaucoup travailler ce que je veux faire
passer la vendre donc mon stage à leur
attaque les filles et les fils du panda
c'est bien contre lui non mais tu imites
assez bien bien tu as
donc bon nous rejetons tous je dis moi
tu as raison de dérives et on va creuser
quand j'aurai fait rock pour emmener les
pièces auxquelles je veux pas réfléchir
h3 quoi aia ok j'ai pas peur de 204 et
ça ça marche toujours pas ok je veux pas
réfléchir ce fait les mots je pars
insistait quoi feu de cave
merci pour la partie donc rock ok mais
moi je ne veux pas réfléchir en fait un
coup quand même constater qu'ils ont en
quelque sorte que vos l'es15 a bien tué
les résultats du ku'damm c'est certain
c'est vrai il est mal passé parce que tu
peux pas faire cas il sait qu'à tu te
fais prendre sa part yvon intérêts et
quand tu fais des cinq classes en iphone
4 et la tourtière bien belgrade où f4 f5
way et donc après tout on se demande
pourquoi le goût et fréjus 1
le coût est élevé parce que c'est maxime
qui n'a pas d'autres jeux 2
en inde il tremble devant les femmes
c'est vrai mais il est marié en même
temps mon moment non il tremblait devant
les femmes disent il devint wrap tant
pis rendez vous galant dans tout le
temps que nous raconte en tête plus tard
non au look et klose après minuit
je n'avais tente qu'ils vont mal tourner
et que aucun problème de cette reprise
tonnes dans deux conduites des 5 mai des
500 f 4 5 mm x f4 ça paraisse enfin
pions prend puis on prend cavaliers en
fou prend faut être quatre noms marquez
il faut aussi retour 2 1 et il ya
toujours pas de calais 3 est un pseudo
parce que le truc de fou dit oh non je
veux dire comme l'e3 et puis il faut
seulement 8 go sont défendus ou le bio
mais défendue donc il fallait il fallait
montrer que même qui viennent qu'il y
avait 5 6 s'il faut déjà parlé tout à
l'heure mais oui ça fait pas de mal de
remontrer et c'est un problème paraît
juste peur du matériel et les noirs
n'ont du coup pas claires la partie ça
va se savoir le problème quand vous
jouez un coup rapide oui puis
l'adversaire fait le coup en preview qui
stoppe toutes les activités pour un
petit moment
il vous vous dites ça merde pourquoi je
fais ce que l'on me pourquoi j'ai pas
réfléchi à voir c'est pas quelques
secondes encore parce que bas avec ça je
crois que tout le monde joue donc il est
possible que ce que ce produit me
manquer si le nord ça vraiment pas quoi
faire parce que bouche et les dents ça
sert à rien parce que tous trois y danse
trad
la dame a bien passé du point de vue
pratique donc si le noir ça vraiment pas
quoi faire et où burdeau petite histoire
et ça roule donc peut-être en commençant
les colères de cette erreur là même qui
peut-être juste en tant que proposition
est ok au moins
si tu n'étais pas bonne ou mauvaise mais
un vieux comme le précise que valeo 6 4
après quoi bon mettant tour dida à vous
sacrifier sur un même bien sûr qui
convergent les cinquièmes jo on décide
sur qui on peut montrer quoi en gros ce
que je voulais faire c'était ça ce que l
air x 1 600 g alias en l'air il ya 100
l'air mais kia temporise encore qui
était ce propos c'est ce que l'histoire
pour tesco a déboursé 4 ça va ça cesse
avant et poupées 6.4 donc sonné 3e
victoire plus que suffisant donc marche
pas l'autre bout marche pas donc aux
livres 2,7 alors il faut trouver alors
la rue m après calais de 7
souvent je dis pas ici me saoul a
souvent que vous avez trois missiles
collector qui valait 3 seul hic l'idée
que les populations
sauf qu'ici ça va d'accord donc essayons
de comprendre
vous savez parfois il ya des trucs qui
existent mais sûrement pas ici c'est ici
bien sûr ça certes arrière à quatre les
deux caps recoller à 2
ici à cinq les migrants sur besoin ici
de 5e quoi le truc quoi mais ici c'est
pas bien joué parce qu'après à 14 bois
juste pour elle parce qu'ici c'est pas
un affaiblissement mère lorsque le
pioneer assis sur a6 emprise
ça peut être un truc existe je voudrais
donc parfois même ce qui marche dans les
terres sur celui des 5 e déco les
dessins que les 2 500 2,5 et aucun sur
trois ans et à 4 et ceux qui on est en
quelque sorte les contradictions aux
principaux femmes mûres
tu attaques sur le côté les taxes sur le
côté doit être puni pour l'élection au
centre et la sel attaque au centre qui
est puni pour l'action a cotée au maroc
et pas ici bien sûr il a fait petit rock
ok ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que il
a trouvé quelque chose d'intéressant
contrastera comptera donc ouais les
plans cyniques que lmh quoi et qu'est ce
que le joueur s'est plaint demandent
s'ils vont jouer qu'une partie classique
aujourd'hui horizons nouveaux
il en nous il en joue une aujourd'hui et
une demain mais un choix assez logique
ok non pas 12 mais peut-être juste une
version élevé offert de 5,4
khawaja 6 4 6 4
dans ce cas de faire baisser non je vais
faire tout un ici de cette fois au lieu
comme ce cas de ces bons ce que tu nous
fais je vais ou peu près impossible 4 il
n'a pas assez de temps pour oui oui si
ça c'est bon donc après que les secrets
de ce jour que cinq tout de suite de 5 à
4,4 2,5 tout de suite collé au cateau je
suppose que oui sinon je pense pas que
tu peux au moins ne voyant que je fais
c'est trop tôt elle vous prend à trois
qui donne envie mais j'y crois pas
bon ok oui et au qe2 j'aime bien le foot
y arrivons des 5 c'est génial ça pour
les noirs je vais dire l'idée éventuelle
c'est quoi par exemple si je crache
quatre stops et maintenant tout est ok
pour toi tu t'arrêtes la liberté pour
attaquer notre côté on va gagner cinq
pieds noirs
non clairement on demande si à l'époque
la différence entre kasparov et toi et
tu es vraiment grande
oui il est bien de montrer ça au cours
de notre mini matches sur la scène du
palais des festivals à cannes
donc je peux pas nier ça parce que
c'était trop visible ou trop visible le
cours de notre image mais dommage que je
pas survécu jusqu'à oblige
parce qu'à l'époque jeté une force
glisse à ne pas négliger
de là à ne pas négliger quand même et
donc ce qui aurait pu se produire en
blitz qui sait qui c'est parce que deux
ans plus tard quand même 2003 j'ai gagné
le tournoi qualificatif aux antilles
minutes
il y avait tout le monde car trop
flamand de hockey y avait pas de kerry
meades tout le monde était là oui j'ai
gagné seul avec lui c'est donc à
l'époque ce n'était pas si mauvais en
bride qui est bien sûr j'aurais pas dû
être favori mais qui sait mais
malheureusement je pas sûr vu que
jusqu'aux prises même si c'était moi le
salua tryphon 140 grand chat
ah ils montrent exactement les variantes
qui n'ont rien de vous montrer de
l'ordinateur montre que les montages 3
vers un gain de 5-4 que les 6 4 5 4 mais
il donne un grand avantage manon
conquois eagle ah ouais ouais j'aurais
pensé que c'était vraiment mieux pour
les noirs salut à ce coup derrière fabio
salua antoon veut at kate en ouverture
préféré mais ça c'est une question
tellement difficile notre nostalgie avec
les blancs les noirs avec un homme très
très facile
pourquoi parce que romantique et ses
lions 2 ouverture très rare maintenant
qu'ils sont très intéressant d'analyser
parce que par exemple stockfisch
comprend pas grand chose par exemple et
donc à chaque fois que vous analysez les
lignes principales de l'esthétique il
faut que vous réfléchissez vous même
parce qu'il faut guider d'ordinateur sur
chaque ligne même un mail il a même lire
ah oui en fait à un moment donné j'étais
plus ou moins de force et analyser ça
pendant un mois
toutes les principales et c'était dur et
compliqué et tout le reste
gt1 sûr qu'on vous dit tous mais ça
c'était un peu ça reste toujours un très
bon celui des messieurs pessah qui dit
que garrett est un des grands joueurs de
l'as saint-etienne qu'est gary reed mais
ce qui est marrant aussi avec le stand
yankees à chaque grand joueur qui a joué
surtout virtuo ayew son instinct tient
car je crache des cendres jouer derrière
oui par exemple il ya et matthew les
statues de guerriers
bien sûr il y en a eu les indiens de
notre docteur n'a par exemple et aux
listes indien de l'intérieur
les stadiers du mois il est marié ou
plusieurs autres celle de beaux la
gamelle en cas par exemple où il en a eu
peut-être une dizaine des gestes
indienne à chaque été différente puisque
c'est tellement un gros coup mais les
pièces comme ça quand les six jeux six
ou sept tirs au cours de six et ça y est
la liberté de la création ne reste
toujours énorme et maintenant donc ça
continue paraître quatre c4 est cher par
échapper
ça va continuer comme on l'a dit non ah
oui le seul grand joueur qui n'a pas su
vraiment jouer le maintien parmi ceux
qui la longe de cet espace qui c'est pas
moi qui paie la note
il est dit que c'est parce qu'ils
considéraient en tant que jeu universel
- deux fois jouent les soutiens quelque
chose ne va pas
est ce que tu penses que ce parce qu'ils
étaient plus forts que fischer non je ne
pense pas mais j'ai ma version sur sur
ce que ce passé reykjavik 19 72 en tant
qu teaser c'est quoi les questions pour
vous aviez violet au film le sacrifice
du pion j'ai pas vu mais hockey pond sak
le fasse
donc est ce matin au big mac ware a joué
fischer à notre très bons acteurs à
jouer spassky mais les questions après
le film avant le film pendant le film
reste pourquoi est-ce-que à maillane
plus de ce parce qu'il n'a juste pas
arrêter le match en forçant ces
conditions qui ont noté qu'ils ont noté
comment dire qu'ils ont été agréées par
la fille de en gros on apprend que c'est
loin d'accord parce qu'ils aient voté ou
pas ce que cherche carrément abusé au
niveau de ce que je sais juste abusé la
maintenance joue pas sur la scène ajout
d'un jeune dans une chambre fermée les
îles à ça donc les choses que vous êtes
donc en course parce qu'il va pouvoir en
place et les victoires en six matchs
plusieurs fois pourquoi ne l'a pas fait
et pour cela les scieries signé qui
viennent parties doivent agir sur le
cours soviétique fans de mes mains mais
je pense qu'il était
petit je vais je vais regarder ça pour
les séries mais ça avec gentil n'ont
fondamentalement bas s'étendre 4 est
très rare qui ont un changement de
gentils ils se sont ils sont terminées
par être très très beau être très très
potes
malgré ce que s'est passé dans les mains
donc ce qui est incroyable il parce que
sinon ça se termine normalement par les
rivalités
regardez le cas de dopage au faou
chronique par exemple dans le ghetto
disons que ils se détestent mon intérêt
maintenant donc 7 juin vous aurez non
mais ça va jouer on va laisser les quoi
rêver parce que ça va arriver puis on
parlera de la position résultante quand
elle arrive à moi de charles que tirer
quelques conclusions
déjà on peut dire que le pari du prix de
personnes de l'ouverture n'a raté à ras
terre n'a pas vraiment marché
en fait c'est plutôt lui qui a souffert
du fait que c'est trop bizarre
maxime à sa façon se débrouillait très
bien dans le vertueux ils risquent pas
grand chose je pense le type de
l'imposition web convient parfaitement
donc ça je pense qu'un peu déjà formulé
ce constat très agréable pour nous tous
deux les agapes
oui sinon on ne sait pas ce que vous
arriverez au maître déjà je pense que
c'est plutôt bien ou très bien ce qu'on
voit sur l'échiquier très bien non ouais
c'est excessivement bien oui parce que
il à paris organisée - vieux le type de
l'opposition il risque grave de gagner
même soleil parce que c'est comme ça que
le 4e au monde
en gagnant ce genre de position espagne
se sait et magnus le sait ce qui est
bien ce pastilles à moscou dans
actuellement ce parce qu'il est à moscou
parce qu ils s'emmerdent est
complètement avec sa famille en france
qui était sa famille en france c'est son
fils et sa femme russe doit aussi donc
russe donc c'est doivent se dire émigrés
quoi qui vaille la reddition avec les
rouges
oui comment elle rencontrait d'ailleurs
pasquio pendant l'union soviétique et le
travail est d'aller bosser à l'ambassade
de france à moscou
c'est comme ça qu'ils se sont rencontrés
donc et les qui ont des sandales d'un
général de l'armée blanche très connu
donc m s à 100 d'eads est complètement à
partir d'un moment donné pourquoi pas
écouté je suis avant ils nous cachent
même pas je pense que c'était les
questions de l'aide de l'agent jeter les
questions de l'argent et de beaucoup
d'argent donc je pense que c'est ça les
raisons donc il vit avec une femme pas
au centre de moscou
mais je pense que ça va bien beau mais
au moins vous savez après avoir eu une
crise cardiaque
il est toujours survivance que déjà pas
mal tu penses ce serait possible afin
que j'ai à moscou devant arriver pour la
chine bitstream une chose ou de garantie
ce jeu bio essayait de tout organiser
parce que je le téléphone dans le
confort non mais ce serait exceptionnel
à voir ce parce qu'ils n'ont bien sûr
mais je peux essayer de leur usine parce
que je pense que même s'il bouge à peine
il est toujours complètement conscient
de ce qu'il dit non ce serait
exceptionnel non aux éau essayons second
temps une attaque ce pas ce qui se fait
seconde option parce que après tout ce
qu'on dit on dit toujours maxime
meilleurs joueurs français maxime
meilleurs joueurs français maxime plus
beau palmarès spassky français quoi
qu'il en soit oui bonjour c'est quand
même un certain palmarès champion du
monde a bien d'ailleurs au cours de nos
séries on va parler même d avoir parlé
au dos parce qu'ils doivent en est
devenu français parce que je connais pas
moins de titres à parler de légumes
à noter ce qui est écrit sur sa tombe
jennir france franco russe donc on va
raconter comment des vignaux ici comment
elle a vécu ici et ce problème en énorme
d'ailleurs pendant les moments trop loin
dans l'histoire parce que pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale pas beaucoup du
monde le sait mais il a eu de grosses
difficultés que c'est parce que sa femme
agit donc mais ok mais un bateau a
raconté tout même les anecdotes
même les anecdotes à fond tout ce que je
pouvais trouver et encore 3 5%
darcos retard que prend soin de livres
de son coup sûr le joueur soviétique
boss exxon j'ai quelques critiques - en
général ce fantastique mais je peux
critiquer plusieurs choses dont je pense
pas que le faux voeux mais sinon c'est
fantastique nous dresser les livres de
gaspard nantes a patronné à magritte
grid perdu ses ressources
j'aime pas du tout parce que pour une
raison très simple je pense que
premièrement dans les premiers volumes
et avait trop d'ordinateurs et dans les
derniers royaumes il n'y avait pas assez
de guerriers de toute manière parce que
je sais très bien comment comment
distinguer son style et je suis persuadé
que c'est pas lui qui écrit d'accord
c'est une bande de journalistes qui a
écrit à sa place ça c'est le premier
prix de la deuxième critique et elle a
croisé un critique ce qu'ils ont lorsque
ça parle par exemple du gros champion
des champions deux jours qui ont été
prises comme les champions comme
morgenstern par exemple trop souvent
c'est bien on clichés trop souvent ce
n'est que les citations de tout ce que
j'ai eu enfin les donc c'est disons que
rire dans les livres de ces livres de
kasparov
il n'y a vraiment pas celle de crespo
est trop de gars et bah oui voilà ce que
c'est par ici comme à l'interview avec
moi et au lieu de commenter je dis qu'il
ya un cent cavaliers 3 way comme ce
n'est qu'une autre vie est possible ici
ordinateur d'ailleurs et en core i3 ou
de de colo a eu 80 ans ouais ce que moi
moi je leur ai fait que répéter les avis
des autres tu vas pas faire
moi je les faisais
et si les autres en raison tu répètes
pas quand même vous et moi n'ont jamais
raisons auxquelles a pris 1,3 et
cavaliers ou quatre bons il préfère
quand même de bouffer l'opium des cases
doigt parce que comme quoi ces lots lot
fou qui bordent les positions des
bouillonnements ce que c'est qu'est ce
que c'est que ce sacrifice n'est pas un
sacrifice 1 il a pris un fou en trois
non non non je veux dire plus grand
plaisir ici de f&a corrigeaient d'eux
qu'ils attaquent le dos parce que ici
s'il veut enfin termitière parce qu'ici
que va lui accorder d'interview dameuse
damas trois échecs match simon kg 2 6%
n'ont donc mais peut-être ils pensent
que ce fou sur trois est très important
pour les voir en tant que vendeur de la
pause mais donc il veut aussi pris il
veut le gouffre pour pouvoir par exemple
bouger de quatre à huit fois plus tard
ou pour pouvoir
comment dire un enfant
matériau question le cavalier sur des
cas après faut soit 3,2 pouces et 5 d'un
v6 dtk tüv attaqué les camions arafat
auquel a protesté la position n'est bien
sûr en rêve dangereux de laisser ces
lignes c'est même pas en rêve c'est
plutôt un fantasme qui dit observer mais
disons que cette position pour max de
beats you de c'est ce que sophie marceau
pour moi quoi monica bellucci ou monica
bellucci ou les deux en même temps quand
même pas encore reçu la réponse qui va
le battre non bah je pense qu il risque
bien parce qu'il reste bien meilleur
mois par exemple ça avec les bois
comptait renvoyer le père au budokan
front si tu joues bien non mais
jusqu'aux théories je ne tiens pas
compte parce que je sais qu'il voit
finir découler vitesse cosmique ici et
ça va être bien moins fort mais moi je
pense que je perds ça directeur et moi
je vois pas de compte deux jours parce
que j'ai 4 h 4 à chaque fois je déjà 50%
de chances que maxime gagne la partie
fifty fifty cent
30 40 parce qu'il est soupçonné en tant
que responsable il comble non sens qui
tremble elle tremble sociale ouais mais
pas ben y'a pas de dire que peut-être il
va obtenir les positions gagnantes et
quand même rien le dauphin et le
tremblay au dernier moment quand même
parce qu'il nous faut ici souvent
quatuor s'est pas les qualifs pour le
choc de la haine
ouais mais du coup je sais même pas si
c'est une bonne nouvelle par rapport aux
candidats de battre ma glisse ici de
jouer la finale vendredi
enfin de soissons la petite finale mais
toujours la finale et d'aller jouer
mardi à jérusalem répète moi s'il te
plaît qu est ce qu il doit faire à
jérusalem pour se qualifier de jeu
contre à l'exemple de griche au cou en
gros il doit faire un tour de moins que
les autres
s'il fait premier tour les autres doit
faire deuxième tour s'il fait 2e tour
les autres doit faire 2 me s'il fait
demi les autres doivent faire juste
final il est qualifié le seul problème
c'est que sifflet final et que l'autre
gagne il n'est pas qualifié en gros ont
embrouillé doit faire un de moins que
les autres ce qui faisait tout à fait
faisable - pas évident du tout encore
que les autres peuvent bien je crois
qu'il a compris donc faisable
alors taux quasi ce hall a donc tracé
mathieu ni vous avez dit quoi sur le
début je viens d'arriver sur piles choix
de magnus j'avais vu ljubicic un super
joueur par correspondance parce que ces
joueurs de tennis joué ça régulièrement
récemment et dans une conversation
laurent m'a dit que c'était une des
meilleurs joueurs du moment
peut-être la raison mais c'était pas
terrible dans l'ouverture de magnus on a
trouvé que c'était assez soupçonnant bat
je pense que peut-être les virtual soi
même intéressante contre 16 ses
adversaires parce que fort c'est aussi
ce oui mais j'étais pas du tout
convaincu ou par ses oies bandama si
lebron lisa à l'idée de jouer aux abois
et d'amour excusez moi mais
2 - autres marqueurs pour ti coin c'est
pas ma tasse de thé coin parce que c'est
bien trop flamand goukoye donc le choix
j'aime bien la façon de traiter nos bas
par contre je me souviens que pas une
seule fois dans sa vie mc nous ont
montré que c'est un excellent joueur de
l'attaquant n'était pas là jamais
ferrata complète c'était un peu de tout
quoi notre jauge de wisques dans quelle
ouverture ça se fait ça je pense qu'il
ya pas de lucho cela me rappelle un peu
tu sais quoi
la dernière partie partie 12 du match
karlsson caruana ou caruana avait joué
de manière aussi soupçonnant t il
s'était retrouvé moins bien il avait
aussi des connais un peu avec sa tour il
est fait un truc bien trop original la
chevêche nikov 1 où il a fait grand
retour chez un tour j'ai deux tours d2
machin et au final c'était juste mal
[Musique]
mais parfois bien normal pour mario
c'est bizarre il c'est leonardo de
bitche écouté puisque c'est bon un
sacrifice de cavale genre qualité prend
b5 non non c'est trop tard prévoir au
moins à manger des 6 à la fin ou moi et
moi et moi on me l'a pas toujours ici
bien sûr non parce que vous me poserez
aucune compensation positionné pour ce
que vous allez me faciliter la tâche à
nous vendre les colons contre votre robe
vous allez enlever les pions a et b et
les mecs vont pouvoir venir vous
martyrisé sur les colonnes est ce que tu
préfères talent ou petrossian pas écouté
j'ai jamais comprenait le jeu plutôt
petrossian je ne comprends toujours pas
après avoir gardé toutes les parties
qu'il a jouées je comprends toujours pas
son goût et d'alu le livre de python
quoi de pickton kilos de béton petrosani
là où il a brisé notre mieux répartie
l'habitat le big one
donc python je sais pas mais je vis ici
mais j'ai vu le résultat
j'ai vu les hommes j'ai lu aux laumes et
le livre avec ses meilleures parties
commentées par lui-même ni lorsque
johnny maintenant et après je suis sûr
je vais jamais comprendre son style et
bien sûr je préfère d'elle même si c'est
pas l'un de mesures douanières pitt en
stratégie marketing et aux siens ok mais
ça s'appelait ça s'appelle comme ça ils
sont enlevés mais chaleureuse jamais
quoi aurais jamais qui que ce soit n'a
jamais appelé savoie dont jean n'a pas
une seule fois
donc ce n'est que à l'occident que ça
s'appelle de cette manière et même temps
les monty python moi tu pars tu partages
aime bien petrosyan pas vraiment mais
j'ai d'autres raisons de ne pas trop
aimer petrosyan à me dire c'est parce
que mon joueur préféré a été victorieux
chinois j'ai failli écrire un livre si
rose que j'étais gosse anglais et foetus
en faisant la préparation pour les
séries sortant à la fin trois fois à la
fin 2010
y en a marre j'ai appris ok ok ce
téléphone j'ai appris qu'ils ont en fait
malgré les versions à venir pour tout le
monde
coach on est parti de l'union soviétique
pas à cause de dépression parka pauvres
à cause de la pression par petrossian
oui et oui et oui j'ai dit hier à port
de sensations qu'historique
donc en fait qu'appauvrir idées pourries
en fait c'est p300 qu'il est prêt c'est
un peu partout que victor a décidé de
partir au pays pas jouer ce tournoi et
demandé l'asile politique
non j'ai un petit petrossian c'est
beaucoup trop cher parce que ceux ci le
caviar et offre un caviar iraniens
arrêtés dont mourinho sait qu'ils ont
été malins avec le caviar sur un peu lu
l'histoire
à ce propos voir comment tu pourrais que
les filles et le style de coach noël
noir de fichiers auquels n'était pas
bête noire de fléchères c'est juste
qu'il avoue le square égale côté
réfléchir donc c'est pas bête
bête noire de son style a été ok est ce
que c'est une bête grise du bureau des
bio au départ on est bien sûr il a
commencé en tant que créateur qui
comprenait rien il a travaillé
énormément mais il restait toujours
surtout le calculateur qui a augmenté
son niveau devenu l'un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde
plusieurs fois champion de l'union
soviétique mais comme moi ça n'a pas
marché mais quand elle a perdu son
premier match comptera petrosyan alors
219 71
il avait l'air un peu près comme mohamed
zaoui et bizarrement c'est d'ailleurs
unique de l'histoire des échecs
ça les a forcées de travailler
énormément
il travaille sur tous les livres les
livres les parties de robustesse et à
l'espace de quelques uns et les deux
réunions le jeu après s'être très très
fort et le meilleur jeu souligne pas
l'inde mais le meilleur joueur des
finales de tout le monde la preuve dans
le match pour le titre contre cas pour
19 62 18 lorsqu'il était mené 5 2 et la
gagner trois parties à l'espace de
quatre parties et trois fois il a gagné
la finale complètement égal trois fois
qu'on t'a capot pour dire que à ce
moment là elle était de loin le meilleur
jeu iphone et donc voilà je pense que
j'ai assez dit sur son style
maintenant je sais ce que tu penses que
karpov était plus fort que kasparov
non bien sûr que non d'ailleurs un tiers
je voulais dire est ce que vous saviez
en pagne ou qui auraient six mois car
pour foyer de la presse russe qui ont
qui aucun sens c'est pas un bon joueur
positionné
c'est vrai que c'est ridicule c'est
juste ridicule et pour en avoir des
preuves
bof maillot à vous inviter son trophée
capot voir que cela m'a fait que ça
savoir c'est une déclaration assez
marrant même à kasparov s'est moqué en
disant qu capot vous parle du sujet
donné les au canada ouais mais bon
carpeaux fille laïla calage maintenant
karpov au canadian chase ayant bien de
jouer bien sûr mais vous savez il joue
quand même eu deux partis classiques pas
mais je sais je fais des petites nulle
part où parfois pourquoi je me rappelle
il ya deux ans je pense
il va nous apporter ce link il a joué
avec les bornes et leur écraser avec les
bornes qui dit julie qui est en jeu au
près de saint georges il génère 2006
forme de mistral et les cases et j'ose
donc ça lui arrive qu'un mode deux
joueurs et ça sent quand même qui
autrement que parce que dans le cas de
kasparov ne le sent pas bizarrement non
car on ne sent pas du tout le sang
peuvent pas du tout mais kaka sera filet
mais peut-être plus gagné que les échecs
en fait peut-être que kasparov il aimait
plus gagné que les échecs en soit je
paye cette impression à l'époque je vois
toujours l'impression et même les toits
qu'ils gagnaient non je comprends mais
je relève toujours l'impression qu'ils
ont c'est quelqu'un qui a aimé les
échecs permis français parmi les plus
grands d'amour réciproque réciproque au
cours de l'histoire de ce surnom parfois
c'est pas si réciproque comme par
exemple les accords et oui c'est l'amour
pour le tchèque incroyable le mec est
incroyable mais c'est pas très réussie
propre à ce que bah disons que parfois
c'est triste c'est triste de le voir en
train de se battre dans un petit haut
point mais sinon l'amour pour les échecs
mais il a joué tours 2 ok c'est
d'ailleurs pour nous dire tout ce qu'ils
ont il veut absolument récupérer
récupérées aux quatre mais j'y crois
tellement pas joué comme ça contre
maxime sa valeur juste suicider riant ok
ces jeunes de comprendre comment ou
utiliser ce temps là ok bien sûr
normalement tu veux offrir aux quais qui
viennent et moi je note que je veux pas
réfléchir et je joue au blitz je joue en
équipe de quatre à quatre mains bah je
sais pas
tiens d'autres des foyers encore
peut-être ou c5 du coup fausse info je
veux d'un v6 bail
il peut donc que se posent autour des
huit mois tout ce que tu veux y compris
tous deux y compris tenter cette je
pouvais je bouge sur cette joute un
modèle est patent il manque un tempo
d'avoir le temps de prendre le café
faire tourner la tête
mais même dans la cavalle f3 ok donc
très rare john est un américain ok
peut-être fou de 5 vous je doute dans ce
cadre je parle juste
d'ailleurs tu peux faire que les
batteries est ce qu'elle est en train de
penser avec l'idée en plus ça est-ce que
c'est fou ces cinq ici qu'elle se sent
que damas de roy cern dame en arbre non
non j'ai pas quoi que ce soit que six
tours source cinq baies 3 watts dans ce
3 3 instauré ce doit être plus ou moins
d'un cas on peut montrer ouais qu'est ce
que tu me l'as rien à vrai dire oui si
les bornes cas sur quatre les noirs que
sur trois mais je suis pas obligé de
prendre tout de suite je sais mais je
pense que rafa d'après la gueule ce
concours est que les gars d'après la
gueule ça à faire un truc comme ça pour
les deux os et donc mais tout et rien de
plus intéressant
ok il est prêt bien vert de jouer et
heureuse parce que le tour défend la
tempe et six dans le cadre du rhdp 4 à 4
ans précise vous deux si jamais vous
nous faire tous toile
la dame devant dieu
éléphant ce petit parfois non mais ils
voient bien l'harmonie pas totalement
oui en gros mon cher ami
on peut constater qu'ils ont maintenu
ses rentrées dans la mode
les collégiens liquidation totale de
stock donc lundi noir non ces cyber
monday quand ils font le black friday il
faut le saiper simplement à ces mêmes
éléments montrent que le black friday
juste une merde qui n'ont pas vendu le
vendredi les revendre le large sur vos
potes je vois simplement 12 heures
mais je n'ai pas abandonné en cours mais
ambition de trouver quelque chose pour
les noirs hockey qui imaginons jojo non
ok et moi j'ai mon jauger une brigade 24
a qu'à faire je pars tu rêves de
victoire aux jeux de 2006 si tu bouges
je bouffe
bonjour pour le moment je veux pas pour
faire ça je pousse sur quatre démocrates
et tour ce cas et parfois tendu d'un
poussoir
allez la france
passion quand tu gagnes à 5
pour sûr dans le point 5 touches états
d'âme
pas moi le piquer
moi j'ai pas de casse chaque fois tu
mourras mais j'ai peut-être même ça
aussi à chaque fois du beau tout chaud
tout ce détecteur serait qu'à nos salons
à 5 oui bravo de masingue damas est et
si je rejoue d'amazon qu'est ce que ça
donnera mais derrière c'est ça marche
pas comme monsieur âgées doivent
résoudre des x lion mais qu'est ce que
je vois après tout je vois rien du tout
moi oui où je vois rien du tout
ouhlala oui pour des 2 tours 4
- ok ça s'accumule ton des 8,3 à cette
sas américaine ans
oui complètement nouveau donc voila mais
l'idée très très près à d'ailleurs une
fois tu bouges le hockey oui donc ça mon
idéal aussi ça peut marcher
ça pose les questions que peut-être
après un peu car il veut pas jouer a
alors dit que c'est complètement perdre
en afrique à 10.624 tour de vis 3,7
collège s'accrochait comme ça c'est pas
mon taux de pauvreté ça ne va pas rater
mais mario ceux capables de voir ça avec
les bons sociale au québec est de toute
façon je fais à coeur de leur vie du
tour et des huit fou j'ai deux dames
baisser jusque là dessus et sur fouet
car ce soit pour ces trois maintenant
way oui je joue le jeu et réaliser ça
d'une manière ou d'une autre à saïx
arrêts
et c'est la ligne numéro un en fait ça
ça par contre de vrais les capable de
voir oblige je sais et irréfléchie parce
que parfois quand il est mieux il blitz
élèves lisent pas c'est une très bonne
nouvelle sauf s'il tremble c'est le
dauphin
[Musique]
sata intel m'envoie limitation balance
je pense que je ne sais pas quoi mais
leur égard mais chance il fait très bien
moi j'ai jamais vu en vrai mais en fait
pour moi maintenant c'est ces
limitations officiel non non mais
l'excellente cette imitation à fond de
sac
qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
[Musique]
qu'elle sait peut-être pas si mal non
oui monsieur est possible si bien
surtout au kef où je veux si tout marche
bien partout pour nous mon cher ami donc
46 minutes grâce six minutes et demie
pour magnus plus qu'une minute pour pour
maxime il vient de jouer faux dessins
écouter pour l'instant je ne comprends
pas les finesses n'empêche que plus
terrible voyez vous je dose quoi l'aider
c'est quoi le dégré diouf qu'est cette
dame c4 mais b3 c'est peut-être ça en
fait tu sais ma crainte n'est pas toi
viens nous un massicot
non mais je vais appeler puce est de
retour dans la variante en fait où on
n'avait nulle cité laquelle on a fait
nul c'était l'autre se tait pas ici mais
c'était non sans contact comme ça mes
mains c'est pas comme ça c'était
différemment mais foulée de raids jouer
moi je trouve que c'est bien très
discret en tant que l' approche toi il
faut de sens que dans ce cadre parce que
j'ai appris que les deux trois ou quatre
tu vois pas vous a gagné c'est un disque
de l'approché de très agressif que même
il fallait voir le tour c'est trois ou
ok mais si moi je vois non mais on a vu
avec l'ordi quoi bouger deux dames c5
tempo et la l'ordi s'affole notre petite
turbine donne plus 160 après cet
enchaînement de coups parce qu'après fou
prend 1,4 tous rêvent des huit tours d2
et on a du mal à comprendre ce que veut
faire le joueur français c'est quoi ce
bordel qu'est ce que c'est chebah je
comprends pas trop ce qui vient de se
passer
aulas et oui c'est vrai que l'on peut
difficilement se battre contre les
tendances suicidaires quoi mais c'est
saint mathieu ne disait que le truc
c'était dame c4 kébé 3 pouces et 5 oui
mais on a regardé ça oui j'en retiens
vallier prendre goût et bien sûr on
avait raison car c'était ça des trois
dames ces trois dames ses trois tours c3
1.4 fou 4 4 tours j'ai trois tours des
trois c'est cette période là qu'on va
regarder
merci mon dieu merci on n'avait rien des
cédantes on a juste oublié
et un beau jour quand ils voient se
remettre directement quand même a créé à
maxime c'est quoi les racines de ce cd
cd cet attentat suicide dans sa 5ème
place oui tempo tempo avec une sur la
peinture les regards l'autre est choquée
d'ailleurs on va bien sûr de pénurie
soient pas tous les jours
de tels cadeaux un joueur est le joueur
le plus dynamique du monde jouent comme
ça ils disent ils disent que c'est une
erreur il ya peut-être plus tôt et
peut-être tams et 4 c'était une erreur
de p g a on le regarde on dans ce cas ça
veut dire qu'à ibb et 3 et c'est à dire
ça à faire un petit nul que ce cas là on
espère atteindre 6,4 sur facebook ok ok
ok ok ok donc et s'est quant à lui à
l'heure de 2000 rsa du côté devant la
mairie biterois c'est plus ou moins
forcé fous ces cinq turbines ce qu'est
le mien mais la turbine est une seconde
que mon numéro en fait cavalier français
cinq d'or ce soir qui est disputé
d'ahmad peut-être six à son idée est ce
que ça c'est bien son style
et elle est folle et complète après ces
quatre blessés mais le truc c'est que il
ne risque pas de gagner non plus parce
que d'autres manières il risque que de
répéter les coups mais ça peut être la
panique celtique pour l'autre brimelow
terrible mais pas celles qui quoi que je
passe très compliqué mais c'est marrant
pour contre tours bolide que va laisser
trois mois que voler par trois équipes
aa ou kk au liban ouais ben c'est comme
aller à 4 turbo core i3 d'abord et je me
casse caisse et hyper oublier bien sûr
jean marc four cheikh probablement sur
ces 6 3e rang tour bien que valider un
toubib trois maires ça semble pas la
fête quoi hélas ici les noirs doivent
pas espérer plus que plus que nulle
parce qu'aucun moqué le fossé 6 ne
participe pas vraiment le tacle trop
opportuniste à moins peut-être comme
une tentative de gagner par contre ce
qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on n'a pas aller
la bonne position je vais mettre ma
seconde sur le téléphone portable
parce que peut-être que notre budget
n'est foutu pour le moment et donc je
vais regarder sur chat bon en même temps
c'est bien dame c4 qui a été jouée par
mesdames cesag c'était bien trop bizarre
oui bien sûr parce que les aucun sens
donc ok ou trois fous ce sera aussi de
faire un refresh on va essayer ça passe
ok faut se caler ses cinq tours ce
simple ce qu'ils doivent améliorer leurs
sites web peuvent pas vraiment parce que
tu rêves soutien arrive alors pourquoi
ça donc neuf personnes pourquoi pas pour
fermer le camp maintenant pourquoi pas
bouffer sur quatre est professeur site
web avec les dom quelques prix sur
requête dans le gard et dans beauf à
pascal touche de damages 4 ou dans sa
toiture jal japan dont je suis un dollar
mais en même temps mais bon ça fait nul
de toute façon et qu'est ce que ça
donnait le kiné j'ai pas compris
ah j'ai compris peut-être dans beauf
tour buffo faut quatre tours 4 tous
trois surtout tour de droit il ya deux
solides
c'est ça ce que je voyais le d'abord
parce que si tu re d'auteur des droits
cédés tous trois ça marche toujours
manger l'impression de plus est par
définition les cavaliers b 3 juin donc
on prévoit alors le plus problème à nous
ici sauf si
maxi on va essayer de truquer
l'adversaire ou furets le faux socios
fausse agression envers damas deux chefs
intéressant même s'il va essayer ou pas
je pense que c'est pour ça que max n'a
pas cherché beckett d'impôt si c'est
tout ce qu'on veut pas chercher parce
qu'il a vu les deux bateaux et
professionnelles et professionnels pour
le truc et il a dû se dire ok peut-être
ça va lui faire peur il voudra pas
rentrer dans fin tu commences à parenté
des histoires aussi non si vous voyez un
bon vous cherchez un pour un autre coup
en cours mieux mon nouvel as cas je
pense que tu es c'était cette fois ci
vous sont beaucoup joué tempo non ça
risque de faire nul est ce que c'est un
bon résultat
je sais pas je pense que c'est plutôt
maxime qui a dominé cette position même
si cette partie même s'il avait écouté
je pense que viol aux résultats au cours
de dernières années ada en cadence
rapide
je souligne pablisme rapide je ne pense
pas que c'est un bon résultat si vous
aviez obtenu un très bon passeur du
tournoi presque dans les rapides sur ma
maxime n'est pas favori mais en vie si
les favoris anglais favoris ou 104 104
mais il est pas moins bien c'est sûr
moins intrépides non il est pas fait
vraiment loin d'être donc si il l'avait
obtenu un bon boîtier noir et la fois le
seuil est quoi donc
donc avant tout un bon résultat mais en
pratique c'est peu c'est vrai qu'il faut
pas trop quoi est ce que tu penses que
magnus aura des bonnes chances de
conserver son titre
ça dépend bien sûr de compter qu'il faut
jouer ça dépend beaucoup contre qu'il
doit jeu
il est plus fort que tous les autres
mais le bureau parfaitement est bien
pire de son match tout simplement parce
qu il est étrange au concept dommage
il sait pas comment se préparer pour il
sait pas comment garder son calme
portant
il fait ils tremblent trop pour son
titre donc ça dépend bien sûr qui va se
qualifier mais je pense bien qu'il peut
perdre le match c'est que jouer souhaite
est ce que tu penses que magnus arrêtera
les échecs s'y perd le match
je pense que c'est possible et ça aussi
on pourrait faire du bien aux rochers
est ce que tu penses que ça serait bien
de sortir notre série vidéo sur le sur
l'école soviétique au moment du match
pour en vendre un maximum
j'en suis sûr je suis sûr est ce que tu
penses que tu vas secondes et great food
pendant les candidats je le pense et
refi qu est ce que je pense que si riche
que ce qu'elle vit pour le moins cher en
boîte à omagh news j'en suis persuadé
est ce que tu penses devais y aller
parce que là bas parce que je veux
travailler jour et nuit pour jour nv
pour du coup y aura pas de serre et
vidéo sur lignon sogeti aaa mais par
contre qu'est ce que ça va se baisser
les qu'elle serait publiée dans
libération
les gazages deux car ce nom on dit un
peu le maître yoda des échecs vous
trouvez pas que je suis plus beau mais
on parle du maître yoda pas le verbe à
l'autre body builder faudra se frotter
les mains d'autres commencent à bien se
passer
d'accord ils sont bien les autorités de
m s'inquiète pas inquiète face à bien se
passer
est-ce que maxime second départ vlad
pourrait devenir champion du monde mais
je pense que 8e fait un super boulot non
déjà à werritty un fouet soupire
bourreau et parfois ça se verrait que
vos moitié aussi
non en fait son problème c'est pas tout
à fait les propositions et de toute
manière ce n'est que les questions
d'éventuels parce que l'image et vous et
moi jamais on me le proposait pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils s'appellent non feinte et
gagne patrick etienne de banon c'est
grâce à eux le boul
et en plus si tu apprécies c'est bien ça
le problème c'est pas ça le coup mais
c'est quoi le problème
bah quand tu vois très une pendant des
années qui est un très fort l'un de ses
concurrents ce pour toujours les
paiements griggio peut-être qu'après les
candidats arrivent un peu lâché non oui
elle est élue pourquoi fuir et 2.5 kg
par l'étrange en accueillant à 25 ans
qui seront déçus qu'il faut affiner nos
mythes sa chambre
[Rires]
pour ceux qui comprennent je veux avoir
des bonnes connaissances non et il faut
un bruit sourd entre le truc je n'ose
pas lui demander une question ok il faut
énormément de travail il se met même à
jouer mais geoffrey se maintient mais
pourquoi plutôt au monde quoi pourquoi
est-ce que contre les français se joue à
chaque fois empreinte de sa trêve si les
jets répondre mais c'est une grosse
question pour moi même ce que je
comprends pas pourquoi est ce que nous
prend surtout cinq sages arrive pas à
comprendre
normalement on prend des sacs sont
contrôlés française le parce qu'ils
veulent pas travailler mais c'est très
vendeur son coeur répondre nous étions
peut-être rien quelqu'un premier vous
qui peut le demander et mathieu même que
les deux plus forts je veux qu avait
libéré mais qu'elle se fasse mal que tu
trouves pas davantage mais tu peux me
chercher on dit qu'elle a beaucoup de
temps d'avant c'est vrai que ça peut
être important parce qu'il ya pas de
rajoutant oui mais pas ici
bah ça dépend sur quel ces cinq dames à
deux ça peut chauffer payet laquelle
connaît déjà deux motos il est bien dans
les calculs et est-ce que mal avec
mauvais avec ma news tu peux pas le
bluffeur concept parce que où il trouve
facilement les coteaux défense pour
quelqu'un jouer tous ses cadres et que
la quête c'est une torture justement
bouge pas pour faire des couilles je ne
bouge pas réduit ça va craquer oui c'est
84 oui ça m'a dit qu'il a regardé on
prend des cinq à la base pour son fisc
et puis d'abord étirer toute la france
est bien joué ça on a ou à laquelle
commence à peler qu'il est secondaire
quel estate n'ont jamais oublié un très
beau mouvement français pour le papa
escapade
enfin un truc que les crocs à quoi
panache oui quel panache à la galloise
d'amado sans réfléchir quoi news pas
contre toi quoi oui quel panache sa
fantastique ya un bon son qui sort pour
une boisson qui s'appelera n'achète pas
mâché ses la musée de la bière avec de
la limonade aller est ce que ces quatre
était le seul coup il a fait des photos
d'eux non il va faire c'est sûr ok
d'après leur dis vous prend 4,6 jouable
mais ça paraît bizarre de se laisser
monter droit à quoi ces quatre c'est
vraiment logique mais sur dame ces
captures c'est évidemment explique
plutôt qu'est-ce qui assure fou ce que
je peux regarder un truc c'est qu'on
alors d'y allumer donc on va montrer oui
sinon c'est pas évident tout du tout du
tout parce qu'on met peut-être peut-être
d'autre chose gagner aussi escale autour
du retour de la tour était en prison est
bien sûr dans ce cas les taux de 2 oui
oui ok donc to be wild c4 au sicoval et
à quatre et on m'a dit que c'est mieux
après chaque échec je pense on n'a pas
su que cette nuit on a dit que l'ordi
disait çà çà çà çà ou et ça ça et ça
mais ça reste très choquant et dans ce
centre où des gens ici même pas quoi le
truc est chaud mais si tu es un moment
que je joue jamais dangereux en 2005
comme jeune tu joues si c'est le seul
coup
sinon que tu au jour où fo 67 5 sous des
5 alors didier galles tour 3 pour écrire
mon chat - ac 3 possède un bateau s'est
retrouvé il ya aucune logique de soleil
enfin quand tu vois est assez logique
mais sinon tu vas dire monsieur la mer
donc
admettons que donnent ces cas l'air
c'est plus facile pour les banques pour
le battant il a fait tous rêvent dé 8 on
va laisser jouer quoi dans ce cadre et
moi je dois faire je connais ce type
je connais ce type qui sait ce qui - si
tu sais il peut faire jusqu'à 35 ou
mythique mont aimé ces quatre îles
affaires - ce cadre il va faire qu'un
bon parce que c'est comme ça qu'il
devienne le champion cas pareil pourquoi
n'at il peut venir d pendant toute la
partie et c'est un fait mais 46 l'as
impressionnant quand même je trouve bien
sûr parce qu'on skie l'héritage parce
que beaucoup de joueurs qui ont joué
contre lui
après les parties dans l'analyse post
mortem l'ont pas trouvée près de l'école
comprise entre le moteur et la jouer
contre caruana avec le noir à 2010 et
les perd 2 à 4 mois ci s'oppose à
l'histoire de fait les mêmes et donc ils
ont vraiment à sa sortie les françaises
peut-être pour la deuxième fois dans sa
vie ok ça bouge ça bouge ça bouge un peu
morte à c'est une position nettement
mieux enfin sur sûr que muse issihaka
mieux ce week-end des 17 et ri qui
devrait être dur de gagner je propose
l'auteur accepté après l on entend les
uns simple il me dit que web
j'aurai un sentier jorion se dit mais si
c'est mieux parce qu à rien s'ils savent
pas grand chose
bagnols justement même est morte à
sensible il très sensible mais rien
s'inquiète tu vois donc il est il juste
nous mettre pour jeu des pièces du jour
je paroisse 8 jouera toujours d'amour
est toujours la même il a besoin de
calculer
d'ailleurs j'ai lu l'interview de l'un
de ses premiers entraîneurs c'était
aussi un entraîneur soviétique
ça pulse vote unique le mec il est la
bête en espagne depuis longtemps et il
écrira un gros article sur le jour du
cancer inca kah walla avant de leur
magie ou à chaque fois il disait que
c'est un technicien génial téthys
ingénieurs tissage et c'est incroyable
pour un tel spécialiste comme ce mec je
vous ai dit de ne pas comprendre qu'un
calculateur aouana ça n'a jamais été un
bâtisseur génial ce calculateur
générerait médias autour ce qu'elle
soutient richard j c'est incroyable 2e
marrant non ouais c'est incroyable ça
parce que ce sont deux choses tout à
fait différentes
bien sûr les gens ceux par exemple je
suis un très mauvais calcul à tour mais
j'étais toujours un bon couple tacticien
encore de tout moyen soit ayant
tactiquement très très bien et lorsque
je t'ai je me situais c'était
je faisais leurs heures de toutes les
républiques du kazakhstan aurait pas
vouloir du pipi caca mais même comme ça
et même du quartier des sept des
cercueils noirs sans l'avertir que ce
plaisir que noah c'était ton quartier
c'est là que ton nez a été cassé non
c'est ouvert au monde a été cassée
pendant tournoi d'élémentaire mais après
s'était classé deuxième fois de ta
cotillard est en récidive et naulleau
moment s'était cassée par la vue sur la
rue badeaux mecs qui m'ont demandé de
leur acheter de la vodka
j'ai refusé et dit frais de prise sur
lui et ça du coup c'était dans le
quartier des noms ans était tout au
centre damas dans le quartier 107,2
n'était pas dangereux de tout mais j'ai
pris une belle nouvelle droite
pas par les mois menée par le genou par
le japon une belle droit pop de jeunes
au talent fou change de genre de chanter
at a fini à l'hôpital une nouvelle fois
mon papa comptant cette fois ci cette
fois-ci cure pour deux ou trois heures
c'est pourquoi oui ce serait important
de thaksin à quelques heures où est la
différence est énorme parce qu de
terrebonne tacticien c'est vraiment
facile je nie avoir léché marin
non il suffit de faire je pars entre
cinq et dix mille d'exercice ses
concurrents d'un travail assez
mécaniquement et quotidien au quotidien
par contre les calculs il arrive que
parfois même si vous faites le maximum
vous n'allez jamais calculé comme les
meilleurs calculateur du monde
je prends mon exemple par exemple je
fais je sais pas combien d exercice mais
je touche je vais toujours inférieur par
rapport à ça donc non pour s'améliorer
en calcul il suffit d'acheter un
abonnement sur une chaise comme les
faire les exercices tactiques
oui ou non rien de rien pour l'attack
calcul c'est plusieurs régions et la
phase iv alors ça et bien sûr pour u se
fasse il s'échauffe peut-être même manu
ce qui va gagner
bon d'un point de vue un bureau en
bureau du prévôt maxi cie la vue aux
commandes et les formules il est décidé
d'essayer de gagner parce qu il a senti
la chance et que le doit l'ouvrir
essayer si c'est par l'autre raison tant
pis mais si il a fait à l'express donc c
d'une décision courageuse dans les
oppose que comme on a dit revendant les
départage rapide n'est pas favorite mais
du tout j'ai regardé deux dernières
statique que c'est à ces affreux pour
moi c'est donc à nancy se passe vraiment
par jour ces lois france et exercice par
jour saison rien pas mais messieurs vous
êtes bien d'un sérieux ou pas vingt par
jour seynois ce même pas c'est pas que
norme bien sûr plus si on parle de
karting les tactiques se doit être
comblé cacahuètes
j'ai pas vous pouvez votre cas vous et
vous devez le faire vous marchez sur la
route de venofer vous attaquez les
fièvres devait le faire bien sûr vous
couchez avec paraît tout le temps oui
oui bien sûr tu as tout temps une
position qui tournant bien sûr vous avez
bien sur balles sinon comment devenir un
bon pâtissier à m alain précise grave
attaque impossible
oui bien sûr ça tourne toujours
donc d'un basket pas possible ce que
yaya toure c2 et du couffo prend ses
quatre ans il va ça marche pas que ce
tour prends ton coin et tours d2 et le
cavalier ses seins qui contrôle les
cases importante
ah oui le fougueux 4 arrive donc les
petits vation du fou lorsqu'il prend sur
ses 4 ce n'est qu'une illusion parce que
d'autres rentrent à d'autres problèmes
qui arrivent par contre baissé qui ouvre
la colombe pour la tour 6 8
c'est pas une blague et puis à ces trois
qui paraît ou et ça c'est vraiment un
moule à cavalia 4 logique aussi pour
revenir courir les cadres importante
ouais et après quoi et après pas trop de
considérations positionnelle mode de
calcul de calcul et de calcul il y avait
un seul les
comment les ceux qui ont eu de la chance
qu'ils sont nommés comme ça ils compris
les docks contestant j'ai d'ailleurs il
faudra qu'on parle aussi dans la série
vidéo de neige mai 2009 ce qui a plein
de gens en france qui pend à une offre
saas pour le deuxième volume mais à
plein de gens qui pensent et le bailleur
a vu au pendant l'auteur pour moteurs de
vos historiques les écoles nationales
donc les coups reçus crédits en dollars
us les toiles y ait un ouzbek a remis un
machin c'est pour le deuxième volet donc
c'est plutôt pour 2021 2022
si vous voulez la nar a pas assez de
l'espace pour parce que dans le premier
volume avoir parlé d'autre chose
mais sinon je me dis donc bien sûr bien
sûr ça mais comme elle n'était pas si
fort que les gens pensent oui bien sûr
bah disons qu'ils auraient coûté si vous
battez les champions du monde
et puis perdre un point d'autres partis
c'est que de toute manière vous allez
jamais vous approchez de du titre de
championne de l'union soviétique par
exemple est un média dont elles
n'étaient pas les seuls comme sale au
kosovo les lots poèmes outils pour être
maudit il était passé comme ça jusqu'aux
qu'il était comme ça dure taille est
fêtée comme ça ça reste toujours de
nombreux vendeurs
il est vrai pas été comme ça et encore
d'autres états xfz vêtements mais ça ça
donne aux zones une partie d'une
opportunité d'analyser ces partis
fantastique mais il appartenait jamais
au milieu des meilleurs joueurs de
l'union soviétique mais jamais vraiment
fait le truc que j'ai lu c'est que j'ai
trouvé des gens qui ont pensé que née
schmitt inaf il avait gagné le
championnat d'union soviétique bon et en
fait il a gagné le journal l'union
soviétique beh oui bien possible - vous
savoir en fait le système de
qualification
des championnats de l'union soviétique
c'était affreux quoi avant le faire à
il y avait du bruit avoir brillé à
baisser après comme ça oui dans le site
ici quietty qui participent dans le c
beliatski toc markov roumanie chine en
gros les mains qui frisait une partie du
top 10 secondes pression citoyenne que
des témoins comme ça top 10 toutefois
souvent ne se sont pas que les virements
pour le bain donc c'était ça l histoire
de ce plat devient suivent
voilà imaginer comment c'était fort
disons que n'importe qui qui s'est
qualifiée de ces abris dumbéa à a déjà
inscrit sur mon homme en quelque sorte
de l'histoire des échecs soviétique
parce que c'était tout un exploit quoi
et chaque tournoi dirait un plus puisque
moi mais toi t'as jamais joué le jeu en
venant de russie
or heureusement je suis [ __ ] et
championnat de russie
bon je sais pas non mais géré à l'époque
tu aurais pu avant d'être français et
jouets ou et c'est à jamais c'est eux
qualifiés ou quoi parce que tu as le
niveau pour bois largement ça
m'intéresse pas ce qu'on m'a intéressé
toujours c'est la vase de sèvres
les premières gelées youm jeu le casser
j'en ai dix minutes après tu les fais
tomber
ouais mais le sexe et le trophée du
champion de fruits en rentrant de
l'épagneul d'ouvrir j'ai cassé la base
et donc du sedif allait regagner haut et
âme à tous les militants qui étaient
hier un autre et c'est vrai trois ans
plus tard j'ai une hauteur c'est là et
reste toujours chez moi c'est ça notre
retraite
c'est impressionnant mais il va et sert
de vêtements de rire non eux mais je
vous ferai mieux que l'olivier skies
savoir me punir et j'aurais pas une
deuxième bonjour lui et avait gagné
contre maximale 2
c'est l'angle alors en conclure en
finale nos premières le prince nous
pleurons deuxième régné sur le tag à
nice j'ai gagné sur de manière écrasante
le championnat de france 2009 et avant
le dernier round j'ai eu un point de
plus que max et avoir les dernières
rondes
le bon messieurs jouer le métier a
annoncé que je joue pas pour l'équipe de
france
rosalie lorsque je vais en prendre plus
que c'est toujours max pas que tous les
mecs comme axe donc se spécialise la fin
de ce championnat
j'en retiens des souvenirs à courir
c'est bien ça mais après tu avais été
aussi mis de côté après des histoires un
peu sulfureuse pour être complètement
pour une aide pour laquelle je tourne
aujourd'hui intervilles j'étais une
fille ruth est donc j'ai payé la dette
non j'ai payé pour le même crime deux
fois oui
la double peine boîte liste est rejetée
boîte restée pendant six mois mais là
c'était le deuxième prix imposés par
celui qui avait aucun droit de me poser
cette race pure j'aime bien le mot
damien non pas juste pour dire juste à
une partie des équipes de france à tunis
que vous parle encore avec jouer à une
fois vous savoir le métro légendaire de
moscou moi je vois pas je pense que ces
biens sont polis comme celle que je
viens en pas et ils montrent là haut est
donc il m'a violée view et mathieu
salles aux usa ue mais les deux contests
a décidé de ne pas continuer les
discussions mais du coup je lui en veux
encore pour ce truc là non pas vraiment
c'est d'histoire ancienne quoi qu'est-ce
que je ne vois narry ce que tu lui en
veut encore moi je m'en fous je suis en
vous répondez juste marrant communaux ni
bottes
oui je les raconte qu parce que je
commande mais si nous jouons aussi monde
là on est bien d'accord j'aurais bien
sûr je m'en fous complètement
c'est juste l'anecdote est marrante
c'est un peu comme les russes qui a fait
avec la wild card qui menait la wild
card aux russes la veille du match de
gris cube contre nv n 1
tu veux dire que c'était un taux sale
coup à je pense que le timing a été
choisi de cette manière-là après tout le
monde était au courant donc à vannes que
les finales
j'ouvre une journée là non se joue émile
cette hausse qui le directeur je pense
que dans les cordes quelque chose comme
ça de la fidh a annoncé la liste des
joueurs de jouer le jeu des quantités
c'était ça aussi
or j'espère qu'il ya un grand nombre
parmi vous qui comprend de quoi on parle
en gros on change les règles pendant 13
ans dans le tournoi pour gagner le
tournoi qualificatif n'est pas assez se
terminait donc c'est extraordinaire bien
sûr donc mais si vous voulez oui donc si
j'enlevais au pas du tout joué pour ce
que s'est passé j'ai des sentiments
assez développé envers parce qu'il est
récidiviste aussi ouais j'aurais eu
naguère récidivistes oui la balle est
prévu c'est ça en fait le truc c'est que
qu'est ce qui fait une fois ça va mais
le mec est récidiviste qu'un multi
récidiviste mais bon la wild card en
soit moi je trouve que c'est normal on
avait discuté ensemble c'est juste que
ça joue en russie ce normal sans risque
il est 75e ce soir tiger greenzer effet
ça oui pour ceux que l'on doute je peux
vous rappeler le tournoi de candidat de
l'organisation de chronique en 2002 2003
je me rappelle plus plutôt 2002 je pense
donc se taire griser par les allemands
donc il y aurait les caubrière topalov
en tant que haut les participants oui il
avoué en participant en allemand et
l'omx apple christopher woods qui a joué
les candidats bah bravo à ceux qui se
rappellent de son nom est donc mais il a
participé au candidat parce que le
tournoi a eu
la place en allemagne donc on voyait
donc de telles choses arrivent au foot
et le sport
alors il a joué tour d2 il n'a pas joué
à cavaler à 4 comme on s'y attendait
c'est que peut-être une bonne nouvelle
mais plutôt sa charge points 9-3 qui au
cabri garde l'ordinateur dacquois vont
nous excuser tout simplement parce qu'on
voit ce qu'il monte elle monte autour de
5 dans ce secteur 12 enfin sans les 2
500 ce poète a touché deux trois dames 3
et fougeux 2 ouah ouah ce boson le droit
d'un autre roi fou de mai sur ton projet
bahram tchèque dans beauf et d'embouts
fouet
donc si tu t'en doutes que moi que soit
trouvé ça moins s'il est capable où il
en est capable
les noirs auraient pu répéter les coups
avant peut-être chercher ce qui fait que
chacun croit ces deux amateurs en 1903
est 3e avec fougue et 3 qui arrive
ces trois dans ce 3 coupes droites chers
amis c'est une grosse minute
non faut croire que les trois donc ces
trois dance 3 est à mourir de froid
comme il est un peu trop mais ya pas
trop pire
arras 3 tours sur ippon josep robinho
c'est bien à ce jour là un peu long
quand même pas rien non non mais c'est
vraiment air pur c'est une combinaison
al adha ouais donc au facile
[Musique]
ton prince snj crois pas quand même ok
plus de chance bien sûr pour qui au nom
une fois le répète et puis de rigueur
peut-être scellé technique typique
haussier donc mais j'ai pas tour des
deux jeux géométriquement j'aime pas
trop pour les blancs tu as l'impression
que le roi est bloquée maintenant oui
mais nous faut quatre pour qui le type
en berry value fund
c'est un bon j'ai pas la chanson en
russie était normal que c'était un petit
cube d'air au rustique tibia speech
[Musique]
[Rires]
avions russes
je vis à vis ont nourri ces mecs ils
aspirent à john of b
ouais je viens demain aussi sur les ours
ont gagné mais ge qui gagne oiseaux
nicheurs sa part émis plus qu'un ami je
connais pas ça mais je connais pas sur
les options rémy quoi ben jemia quoi ils
viennent de sauver quoi qu'est le
chippendale de héros et jean gars qui
s'appelle roquetoire aussi quoi manger
ouais avec le hic la moustache la cie va
bouffer le fromage de roquefort vous
écoeurer parce qu'il lui faudrait le pif
et du coup ses moustaches des galets
fromage bien maîtrisée par l'odeur du
fromage mais en français a en france il
s'appelle tic tac tshibanda
c'était un objet ses équipes andalousie
et commence à la chan s'est penché plus
du goût moi je fais une chanson en
anglais qui est pareil
tic tac se dépêchent à l'aide non mais
sur la fin au sit in des tic et tac tic
tic tic tic tic tac
oui oui c'est moi je coule tu toc toc
toc toc toc toc rangers du ris ques les
tic tic tic et tac rogers duris et les
rangers du risque majeur du risque et
que je te dis qu'il va répéter il va
répéter une fois peut-être
et après il va réfléchir et réputée
calme tu penses d'objets au niveau de
sans abri au milieu de sans abri groupe
6 julien de revenir qui gagne 20
personnes en fait news news prénom tic
tic tic et tac c'est fantastique m sur
un stream déchets voir ici à parler de
chippendales non mais c'est bien
peut-être de chippendales quoi et
roquefort quoi chipettes d'algues tu dit
chip jeudi des lois de l'école
soviétique et l'école de tennis
elle veut se barrer de la table deux
occasions avant de prendre les décisions
critiques
il faut toujours
aller aux toilettes toujours toujours
pourquoi pour possible par hasard n'est
pas faire ça sur l'échiquier quoi je
vais je veux dire pour notre mrd sur
l'échiquier excusez moi en france
donc bien sûr il faut donc comme iron
regarder les situations globalement est
ce que je dois à risque et maintenant
quelle est la situation de l'image eesi
et ça parce que et puis donc cyril a
requis 10 pour vérifier sur le terrain
pour vérifier sur le tilly fond de ton
adversaire qui veut les laisser dans les
toilettes
il date de couvrir le prix quoi faire un
géorgien non qui avait fait ça oui il
planqué son téléphone dans les
chercheuses et une année je serai à
faire pour faire comme ans après pour
faire de la cause le dernier terrain
oui pour faire leur oasis assis sur les
lieux après deux rondes au pérou du
redoux le trône des frères coen dragons
qui ont photographié d'ailleurs
peut-être parmi vous ceux qui nous
suivent ya quelqu'un qui a filmé
réussissent dans les toilettes pendant
le procès que therrien quelqu'un parmi
vous qui peut nous raconter plus j'étais
celui qui appelle ça le trône de
céramique
ah tiens si les bases de cette série
elle faisait le chrome des sources les
joies de chèque peut être doit faire le
tronc des formes des coupes des coupes
de coupe une sorte de trompe coupe quoi
tintin d'hergé entendu une théorie est
géniale sur game of thrones où il est le
vrai méchant de l'histoire où il en fait
c'est le job no non droit le mans le
groupe axpo rajam à fait exact est
toujours soupçonné
j'ai toujours soupçonné qui résument au
foyer pas pour rien quoi qu'il fabrique
quelque chose avec bran en fait dans
l'île a d'ailleurs d'ailleurs déjà
pauvres il fait bon parce que rehaussent
il n'a pas participé avec toile
ouais où il s'est pas pour l'heure on
trouve en 3d est en fait la théorie
c'est qu'en fait c'est pour ça que le
roi de la nuit et des si facile à battre
parce que lui l'a fait rencontrer toutes
les personnes comme il fallait tout pour
encaisser le trône et il a tout
manigancé du début quoi enfin et oui au
delà des anglais sans dieu qui s'y
intéressent pas ouais congrès church of
wwii quadrettes chabot m'a faite et les
taux calculé d'achat elle voulait y voit
détrôné le du breton leduc norvégiens
ola
tiens c'est intéressant et du coup
manier ce serait des risques mais c'est
incroyable que personne n'a jamais dit
et qui au japon faisait brunswick ont
totalement tard il ressemblait pas oui
vraiment intéressant
la menace d'un peu trop haché mais notre
histoire
la menace que c'est toi qui viens de
voir comment sortir un livre un jour
voici maintenant mais c'est le jeu du
chat which are moment donné quand tu
quand je serai dure trop longtemps en
fait
riou secours moi je pense qu'il devrait
livrer les bras bien haut mais ça
devrait il se fait passer pour un
médecin d'avoir forcément dire que
chrétiens et les rênes de dragon ça va
plus ça va le payer très probable et
marne où ce mouvement donc ça doit le
prêtre chrétien 10e mois demain s'il te
plaît est-ce que ça devrait quitter
l'airé des dragons des dérives demain tu
la vois ont pris en blond par des murs
eux et en plus tu sais les rocher de
monaco 5e comme les rochettes dans leur
ville de way katia bengana rice tel ami
ainsi quinzaine et d'énergie c'est
kitsch ou non maintenu ce quoi je peux
pas ok il me dit que je suis un mais
c'est tout l'édifice ou six ans
mais s'il te plaît non ok moi je deviens
de plus en plus moche quoi je parle à
personne je suis les hommes est
machiavélique
tu te rappelles littlefinger c'est vrai
j'ai testé l'hythane fille oui mais
voilà pas ce quinté les gens là ce bon
match fc edmonton
oui c'est bien le seul d'ailleurs jeu
d'ailleurs vous savez je n'ai je me suis
jamais prononcé ces délais ont fait à
chaque fois que j'ai vu ce mandat je
pensais à saint cannat symantec d'iris
débat risque avec ce petit tweet quoi
tient une fan de cavani pro 4 c'est quoi
on voit vous le dire très facilement c3
c3 comme les c3 fou 3 croissant de
membres sur l'échiquier
comment dit on a trouvé pas mal de gens
déjà
un symbole qui ce sont les dragons cet
officier loi allait toucher le voir les
vrais trois affichent des bilans fait
défoncer le mur est aujourd'hui ward
il faudrait que ce soit y compris ce
soir tu vois le blog ça mais il a bien
fini de mes personnages
la fin était heureux qui voudrait que
tous les week-ends quelque chose et aime
bien les autos séverine reason expliqué
roy c'est un jouet perdre et qui pensent
qu'on est bourré pour le stream en fait
pas du tout rien toi et tu sais ce qui
me rend que chic et choc m'a appelé et
m'a dit voix de maître depuis quand tu
te pour les gueux l'avant commenté jeudi
par une fois d'allemagne et arrête je
connais ta gueule comme t'es bourré ou
pas en fait ce que tu as comme arrière
avoué et je ne peux pas bouillir donc
comment quelqu'un c'est pas vrai c'est
marrant en fait mes chers amis quand
vous êtes bourrés ça se sent sur
l'addiction l'addiction imputant
facilement complet au niveau de
l'édition
si vous parlez vous vous parlez beaucoup
n'ont en fait pas ce qu'on rigole
beaucoup et que vous me s'amuser tout ça
d'ailleurs ça veut dire beaucoup sur
notre société
quand quelqu'un est heureux et qui
s'amuse on on a du mal à imaginer que le
bonheur est naturelle tu vois ce que je
veux dire non mais c'est philosophique
ça doit forcément être liés à nos
risques je suppose qu un type de
conneries pour passer le message
quand même des gens qui nous connaissent
le savent non son habitude le bonheur
est dans le pré ray donc
on fera les commentaires ensemble grand
prix de jérusalem écoute on sait pas
encore c'est toujours une question de
budget quoi qui vient se bat pour je me
bats pour eux donc on dit ça répète les
couilles ça à faire nul ok las
ok c'est la dernière fois qu'il produit
ouais c'est maintenant qu'il doit défier
manon qui doit digérer
donc moi peut-être vaut mieux qu'il ne
faut pas à temps une hausse qu'il faudra
trouver des cours encadrés des coups
extraordinaires premier de trois noms
c'est déjà 3 c3 des lieux déjà accordés
accordez moi quelque chose faite
good game over
bien sûr tout apprécié mon tour j'ai
trouvé des jeux de très fins même
conception donc qu'ils ont d'âge public
vous pensez que le défaut je sens que 3
words avant tout genre va être réputés
ou pas ou pas par vous par exemple ou
jamais jamais par new way et du coup ça
veut dire que demain demain je commence
à une femme toi tu iras monaco présente
yvan devault et donc de moi je revois
les rênes des dragons je vous dis après
demain alors et on va faire une petite
vidéo résumé de cette partie
ouais pour voir donc demain matin on l'a
sortira et voilà je mets juste une
petite pub pour terminer pour les gens
qui veulent
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
toujours un plaisir de dire n'importe
quoi c'est n'importe quoi mais bon pas
et voilà quoi
il faut comptable un truc à pendant les
trois minutes de pub mais on peut me blé
en dix ans et en fait non mais ça va
faire non mais c'est une partie
intéressante à regarder tu vois analysé
pas grand chose à dire ok plutôt terra
nova trouverez de très braves
j'ai 46 ans message aux autres et
pourtant c'est pas mal joué on ne peut
pas dire qu'ils sont musulmans sur deux
s'était bien joué peut-être quand même
au lieu de 6 3 hier d'autre qu'à ma
moyenne plus intéressante
ah oui ana ana ana voter même en fait à
la frottée aux spectateurs qui faisait
s'arrêter
c'est vrai qu'il faut avoir de secret bu
au moins c'est possible ça devrait être
intéressant il faut 3 damage deux
collèges saint croix rouge qui comparaît
terrorisme et continuer juste parce que
le terme misère donc c'est tout à fait
possible mais oui mais il faut avoir du
courage
ouais très intéressant que je suis en
cascade
ok les noirs ne sont pas obligés d'en
que c'est la tour bien sûr mais nous
assumons franchissant cachent quatre
mois c'est logique
et n'oublions pas fou je sais pourquoi
est ce que les six bons aussi parce
qu'il ya en grande partie ils sont quand
même les descentes pour le montant est
comme un faussaire ce concours coup
quand même plus sicilienne que les
conneries je trouve a toujours donné tu
as alors dit que ça c'est ok pour les
bulles noires mais j'y crois pas du tout
même si nan mais du coup par qui sent
pas bon sur ce on vous dit à tous merci
à demain 17h du califat b après demande
17 heures avec toi ok la continuation de
délire ne vont pas tarder ciao ciao ciao